the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
we're getting wild at the super bet
chess classic in beautiful Bucharest
Romania players are on the prowl and
sharpening their claws to fight their
way up the standings reigning GCT Champa
lareza ferrugia got back to an even
score with a solid win over Bagan dayai
the battle of the former Challengers did
not disappoint with Fabiano caruana
grinding down co-leader yon napomiacci
for the win there's a new king of the
leaderboard can he be dethroned day five
of ferocious chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day five of
the 2023 Superbad chess classic Health
here in Bucharest Romania we start the
day in front of two iconic landmarks
here in the center of Bucharest the
statue of mihai eminescu as well as the
Romanian Athenian while we've had some
fantastic just up to this point let's go
to the studio in St Louis and start day
5 Ash
we will welcome you to the first step on
the 2023 grandchester and our coverage
of Superbad Romania we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
hello and welcome everyone to our show
thanks for joining us again I'm Nazi
paikidze and I'm here with my brilliant
co-host the Astro serawan like really
good Hostess right let's see it's been
great calling the action with you in
part yesterday we thought it was going
to be a quiet day right but at the very
end we had a lot of Victories oh yes and
we after the last round emerged the Soul
Leader Fabiano caruana which makes
tournament even more exciting absolutely
hello everyone and Welcome to our live
coverage indeed we are in round five and
we have a soul leader it was packed at
the top but one Fabiano caruana grasped
the mantle and isn't so late it's in
indeed let's take a look at all the
standings Nazi do the honors please uh
so in the first place at the moment we
have American Fabiano caruana with three
points followed by American Wesley so
and Romanian Richard rapper with two and
a half
it's chasing back and with 50 we have
alireza fieruja from France representing
new world champion from China at the
England and Dutch number one anishikiri
and with one and a half we have mvl from
France defending Champions not looking
so good today
young Christoph Duda from Poland right
and with one point Romanian Bogdan
Daniel dick and tell us about the format
right we have a 10 player around Robin
with a classical time control 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves 30 minutes for
the rest of the game and 30 second
increment from move one exactly their
natural offers and there's a regular
scoring system with one point for a win
half for a draw and zero for a loss tell
us about the remaining schedule of the
event right today players are playing
round five and tomorrow they will have a
rest day everybody's looking forward to
tomorrow after that they'll be back to
play four more rounds and the tournament
will finish on May 15th wonderful and of
course calling all the action alongside
as has been far lar good to see you this
morning uh looking forward to another
exciting round of Chess good morning
guys yeah very exciting chess and we had
the interesting round last round and two
decisive games Fabiano winning against
Nepal in this equal end game and firusha
getting his first win so I'm looking
forward to the rounds today but let's
take a look at the standings and at the
top we have Fabiano caruana with three
points plus two score he is the clear
leader of the tournament and then we
have two players tied for second place
Wesley saw who who perhaps could have
had even more points actually he had
some missed opportunities and Richard's
report
now now let's take a look at the road
ahead for this uh leaders here so he's
playing a deck definitely a big
opportunity here for Wesley dick has
been struggling he's been getting it to
time pressure every game so I see a big
chance here for him in this round in
round six he will play the new world
champion dingleren this should be a very
interesting and tough matchup and of
course in round seven he's playing the
leaders karon of Fabiano caruana that
should be a very very tough American
matchup
then we have Richard report he is facing
Anish giri Anish has been very solid so
far with four draws then he will play
mvl and in round seven I see a big
opportunity for Richard here to try to
win this game against
and now the leader of the tournament
Fabiano is playing Duda who's been
having a pretty difficult tournament so
far even though Fabi is playing with the
black pieces I think he will try to
maybe complicate the position and maybe
look for some opportunities here and
then round six who faces firusha should
be a very interesting top matchup and
round seven he is playing Wesley saw
we're gonna go to Romania to our
colleague Grandmaster Christian chirilla
thanks for and welcome back chess fans
to a Bucharest Romania for day five here
at the 2023 Superbad chess classic and
this is the day before the rest day so
you know the players are going to try to
live it all on the chessboard every
single ounce of energy they will try to
muster in today's round but one game
that I'm definitely having my eyes on is
a battle of Champions that is the game
between Ali Reza firuja the defending
grantchester Champion against the newly
crowned King of the Jungle the England
the world champion and this one is such
a hotly contested matchup no wins for
either of the players four draws but you
know today both of these players are
going to try to break the ice and as you
can see right there Ali Reza firuza
coming off hot from a very important
Victory with the black pieces yesterday
against Bogdan Daniel dayak I have to
say completely different ways in which
they got where they are today at 50
percent alireza lost against Wesley so
but yesterday as I already mentioned
bounced back with a crucial Victory with
the black pieces against both Daniel Dak
and I have to say the last few rounds
Ali Reza is definitely looking like he
is hitting up in this tournament one
player that is not hitting up is dingley
ran up to this point but we know he's a
slow starter he had some problems in his
match up against janepomniashi but
outside of that his tournament has been
pre-tamed so far nevertheless this one
is going to be a huge clash and we have
so many others the atmosphere here guys
in Bucharest is just simply electrifying
the fans are ready for a day five we as
commentators are ready and as you guys
already saw the players are coming in
hot as well we have some exciting
matchups on our hands thank you
Christian indeed a big Clash there as
you've highlighted but lay the table for
our viewers nanji and tell us about all
the pairings for this round five
okay let's say today's matchups we have
Yanni partnership playing MBL both of
those players are going to be looking
for a win
do die against our sole leader Carolina
right uh firushpa against ding great
match Wesley saw against diac okay
Wesley's thinking I got the white pieces
I got to perform he has to try and Anish
Gary against Robert again Richie is in
good position but uh Anish if he's going
to make a shout now's a good time and
there's lots of fights ahead what are
they fighting for as we get a view of
the players uh taking their seats and
shaking one another's hands they're
playing for a lot of money there's a
total price fund for this tournament is
350 000 and the first place winner is
going to get one hundred thousand
dollars second place 65 000. third place
forty eight thousand very handsome price
fund all the way down to the 10th and
final position of ten thousand dollars
everyone's getting a good paycheck 13
Grand chest tour points up for grabs you
win clear first you get a bonus of one
tie for first and you start splitting
the grand Chester
player with the most grand chess tour
points at the end of the tour gets an
additional bonus of a hundred thousand
dollars so grab those grand Chester
points quickly and early as we see our
tournament leader there Fabiano with the
black visas and you know even though in
this four rounds you know a couple of
players have got Targets on their back
[Music]
but you can't always beat the targets
too you know definitely not as we're
getting ready uh we hear some of the
public announcements and we've got a
couple of uh
first moves if you will
uh three people be making ceremony on
first moves I believe
make
possibly even Forester not only in
Bucharest also
supporter of the Marshall around so at
the third table it is
the current leader of the brown
um
the CEO of teaser one of our many
sponsors wonderful that has c24
she's ready to go uh makes the first
move there
it's very very nice not only when you do
have sponsors but when the executives
show up and uh and give it their
personal endorsement if you will uh I
always appreciate that so thank you
committee and I'm glad to welcome her on
stage for owning the day of the dark
ladies
yeah
she is a Romanian dancer wow yeah she's
shaking all the competitors hands you
know not just the ceremonial first move
okay
come on Wesley
make a decision
thank you
now
that I'm thinking about it I don't think
I have ever met a fencer champion
I've been missing out I got to get out
more
and we have one
final person I believe who will be doing
an opening first move we're expecting
Sasha Sasha tragic
who is the founder of the super bet
group
the namesake sponsor
um
[Music]
you might not have uh Sasha today
people who are more upon us and some
surprising Insight on the head head
between these two players
wow mvl has a big list
that came out of nowhere only a single
win for nepo
and six losses wow didn't see that
coming didn't see that coming your head
across sure
and uh
whoa look at that E4 C5
but uh not an open Sicilian the allappin
c2c3 which it's been a while since I've
seen this on this level exactly I'm
trying to I was just trying to guess
myself when was the last time I saw it
at the very highest level very popular
at the club level avoiding you know the
night offs and the taimanas and the
dragons E4 C5 C3 is this something that
is a part and parcel of nepo's
repertoire do you think it may be World
Championship prep uh it's possible it's
you know because you spend so much time
preparing for the world championship
yaser and you know you look at some of
the sidelines maybe idea for one game so
perhaps he prepared for one game this C3
and he's thinking this is a good moment
to try to play this and surprise and we
all with it yeah and Nasi raised a
really good point that it at the very
highest levels uh it's not a move that
you see that often um
for yourself when
what was the last really really high
profile game that you can remember
featured the 2800 guys
uh I think I've seen it in Blitz more
often but in classical I can't recall
yeah
yeah I am I'm I'm having a hard time uh
finding a name by the way I remember
this was like really hilarious so at one
time in this career for whatever reasons
Hikaru
uh enjoyed playing after one E4 E5 Queen
H5 right like okay just a terrible
terrible move we understand and uh he
was getting away with it so against E4
C5 he came out with the outrageous Queen
H5 anyway which is like really even more
ridiculous and I remember one opponent
finally said okay enough's enough and go
ahead and have the pawn and Hikaru went
down in flames it was really good E4 C5
C3 I don't know why that inspired me to
mention Queen H5 but there we have it C3
and I I think MBL is just tanked for a
moment yes yes he's trying to figure out
what to play of course D5 is the main
main line and uh n Knight F6 so we have
both options here D5 or Knight dev6
probably gonna see one of these moves
played uh so he's just trying to maybe
remember some of the analysis he
probably haven't haven't looked at this
in a long time no very decent option
against c2c3 of course is E7 E6 d2d4 but
when you do get into this position you
should be per be prepared that's black
to play against an advanced French and
that is why D7 D5 takes Queen takes D5
and I remember even from the Gary
Kasparov deep blue match wow in
Philadelphia
uh see you can get this position or
another very popular
line of play is to play D4
apartment Knight F6 and D4 right and
jump over to you bar and what do you
whoa what do you whoa what's going on
yeah we have a sharp opening here Arcane
Galaxy and we have a Duda playing with
the white pieces and he's in a situation
where he needs to try to win a game yes
sir if he wants to finish high up he
needs to try to score a game at this
point if he just makes draws it's just
not going to do anything for him so he
decided to play a very sharp opening so
let's take a look at the current
position okay and how they got here so
it started off with um e45 Knight F3
Knight C6 Bishop B5 A6
and standard Theory and we see an
aggressive move Bishop C5 here again
Fabi going for some sharp uh sharp lines
here perhaps also trying to have some
chances to play for a win with the black
pieces do that play day four now after a
40 threading a takes B5 so you have some
options with B4 or Rook B8 is another
alternative here still a major Theory at
this point and uh I see about 1200 games
played in a current position D6 so we
continue with D4
and now A5 is played so if you're if
you're wondering why for example black
cannot just take you cannot take with
the bishop because of the simple move D5
deflecting the Knight and then you're
gonna lose the bishop on A5 and if you
take back with the knight in this
position
and then actually the best move here is
Rook takes A5 sacrificing The Exchange
and if you take back you play D takes C5
and now the Knight is under attack and
if you capture white has a very very
strong initiative after Queen takes d8
King takes d8 95 in fact a very very big
Advantage now threatening to play Knight
C6 and Knight F7 this would be a
decisive Advantage for white so that's
why after the move A5 Fabi played Bishop
A7 which is the only move here
essentially so now we have H3 important
move here to prevent Bishop G4 and also
Knight G4 at some point and now we have
Bishop B7
white black is just trying to develop
his Bishop here and
we have couple of more moves Bishop E3
played Knight E4 actually sacrificing
the pawn uh still in theory here about
50 50 games played Rook E1 and Knight E7
so this is the this is the current
position here and uh White is down a
pawn but the best move according to the
engine is just to play Knight bd2 and
just continue with the development here
and if Knight takes D2 Bishop D2
and still I see one high profile game
between Hari Krishna and Gawain Jones
here and the white is a little bit
better here after Castle
he takes E5 and if you capture only five
you have Knight takes E5 move very sharp
opening choice and ambitious ambitious
start I think Duda is trying to generate
some good winning chances for himself I
noticed that as you were going through
your analysis there far
Duda had a chance after Knight takes E4
he played this move rookie one I think
to play the move d4 D5 and potentially
win material A variation he did not play
could you tell us because I can see that
the engine is suggesting the move D5 and
he didn't play that move how would that
how would that have continued let's take
a look at this actually very good
question yes and in fact in a database
there is a game of Duda with the white
piece against with it really okay it's
from 2021 here but the way the theory
will develop here after this move about
20 games I see here in a database so
Bishop takes E3 right and if you take
back with the pawn this is just bad 97
block is just going to be up a pawn so
you have to take on C6 now now two black
pieces are hanging yeah but now white
has this move Knight takes F2 okay and
if you just yeah if you take with the
Rook then I think after Bishop uh
actually sorry just Bishop takes F2 King
takes F2 Bishop C6 and actually you have
three pawns no that's a rook this is a
lot of material here black will be much
better here but I was thinking Queen D5
or
in after Knight takes at f2 couple of
moves right yes you have Queen E1
attacking the bishop you have Queen E2
is the top move here and even Queen
defense let's see here Queen D5 that's
crazy yeah yeah pretty crazy I agree
here black can play even Queen F6 no
kidding and now protecting uh F7 and um
if you take on B7 right E4 check this is
winning for black now because King H1
there is Knight G3 also the same problem
if you go to H2 there is a queen F4
checking nasty check so
you can really take on B7 here but you
can play Rook takes F2 okay then uh
block can play Bishop C8 here
you're going to take on F2 eventually
and perhaps put the bishop only six uh
it's showing actually a little bit
better for black in this position what
an amazing variation wow and it goes to
show right how deep your analysis has to
be your preparation has to be enormous
and I beg your pardon what conclusion
did you reach about the current position
bar we're still in theory are we
yes we're still in theory yes there are
about 10 games played and it's the
engines are showing slightly better
position uh for white but I think
Fabiano is playing very quickly and
confident I think he's analyzed this
position deeper so I wouldn't be
surprised if he comes off some with some
ideas but one of the main moves here is
Knight bd2 just as I mentioned just try
to get a development and another
alternative is just to take only five
and now this move actually forces the
move Bishop takes E3 and after that
white will play Rook takes E3 and black
just cancels and doesn't look like there
are any problems for black here now he
is King is already
castled and pieces are well developed uh
Knight bd2 for example could be played
but black can respond with the move
Knight C5 and looks like in Black's
knights in this position yes Knight F5
ideas coming up so it looks absolutely
fine here for black
yeah well Fabby definitely uh seems to
be relaxed as he's doing the pacing as
is nepo and usually again on each Geary
are the Pacers
um
I wanted to say that as we came on the
show we were all highlighting uh Ali
Reza our grand Chester Champion
defending Champion versus the new world
champion dingler and let's just drop in
on that game and see how things
developed again dingler in playing the
black pieces having a very quiet
tournament and as you pointed out VAR uh
Ali Reza getting in a shot yesterday
taking a shot earlier both players at 50
percent looking uh at that uh
a pack of leaders in front of them
saying
we need a win yeah somebody needs to win
we have another real Lopez exactly with
the bishop
Berlin D3 right yeah it's a Burley yeah
and I always felt that after this move
Bishop C5 that black actually has what I
would describe as a strategic threat
which is the Strategic threat is that
the night on C6 strangely enough is not
as good as the Knight on F3 the Knight
on F3 not only defend attacks the E5
pawn it defends the king and in many
cases the Black Knight finds itself on
the wrong Square standing in front of
the seat Pawn you end up playing a 97 or
sometimes a Chicora Knight A5 so if you
Castle black gets to carry out this move
Knight D4 attacking the bishop and
although a lot of games have continued
like this Knight takes D4 Bishop takes
D4 I've always considered that black got
to carry out a strategic threat of
trading a slightly lesser night for the
better night on F3 doesn't mean that
he's got automatic equality but you can
imagine black is about ready to play c66
it's pretty easy play that is why I
believe the move c2c3 is not only the
most popular move but in some ways in my
way of thinking a necessary move C3
castles castles D5 now
whenever black gets to play D7 D5 if you
don't punish him it's sort of like he's
played in the center for free and so
let's see if in fact uh Ali Reza can
punish a ding uh early trade on on E5 A5
and we are still deeply in theory and
what does theory tell us uh about these
positions VAR is
is the opening move uh still enough for
anything serious or not as much Theory
here Yasser but I see some really high
profile games here so for example we
have a game between Carlson and kramnik
or Wesley against Hikaru rajabov against
Nakamura a lot of high profile games and
it looks like mixed results block is
actually doing okay in this lines and a
couple of wins I see
so after the move Queen C2 black uh
plays Queen E7 pretty much much
exclusively here all the games I see
here are after the move Queen E7 here
the idea is you want to defend your E5
Pawn because I think at this point
already white is considering to take on
C6 and maybe pick up the pawn only five
so Queen E7 and now on white can play
the move A4 here which I think is a
logical move here try to prevent black
at some point from playing A4 and also
securing the B5 score so later on in the
game when you put the Knight on C4
you're not gonna have you don't have to
worry about the move B5 here but here
actually the best move is actually very
interesting it's you play the move
Knight B8
you're avoiding this idea of Bishop C6
and now you want to just regroup here
put the panel on C6 let's say Bishop on
G4 and you can play Knight bd7 here and
looks like black is actually doing fine
in this in this line here uh Knight B3
you simply play the move Bishop B6
and uh if you continue with Bishop G5
if you just just play a logical
developing move then C6 comes in
Bishop go back to E2 to H6
so just a very solid position here I
don't see any any advantage here for
white yeah and then they're Head to Head
Clash neither players ever managed to
defeat the other only four games and
that's not that surprising because Ali
Reza is so very young I believe all of
them 19 years old but uh there you see
them
um
when I see these E4 E5 structures one
player that I studied very seriously as
a teenager and I'm really really proud
of myself that I managed to pick that
player Paul Perez
Paul korres was absolutely phenomenal on
both sides of these E4 E5 where the
d-pawns are gone and it was sort of like
he really really really set a very very
high standard and uh from my study of
his games I've always liked
the white side and the fact that the
night on C6 is so oftentimes misplaced
as the pawn on C3 does this great job of
controlling the Knight and then
Knight B8 is a demonstration of that but
let's jump to Bucharest and Christian
with a special guest
thanks yaser we are with Hans Holger
Albrecht the chairman of the board at
the superbet group Hans Holger welcome
to the show tell us a bit about the
similarities because you're big in the
business world the similarities between
chess and business
well I think the there are many probably
I think the one of the most important
one is that you have to to think long
term in bill as well
um quite often there's the risk that you
go very short term and I guess it's the
same in chess if you if you're just
actual term you may lose out at the end
so the kind of long-term Horizon is
probably the first point and the second
point is um
when you're in a competitive environment
know your competitor try to analyze your
competitor
and in the fair game try to hold smart
team I think that's probably the most
two biggest comparisons you have and we
know that super bad super bad group
super bad Foundation they're big in
helping the Young Generation aspire to
these Great Heights of these players
that we have here on the stage tell us a
bit about that and how important it is
for them to for the Young Generation to
think analytically to study chess things
of this nature
now first of all I think it's important
from a company point of view that you
you take care of this it's it's not a
big company like super that can't be
just for business and and uh for for the
product as well giving back to society
helping Society to develop
and for young people of course when you
talk about Chess it's uh I mean it's
focusing on something for for a while
which is uh which he intended spamming
up nowadays with the young generation is
very different and secondly as well as I
said to train your brain to to think
various scenarios to analyze and then
come to a conclusion as well again which
is a board in life because you can
analyze things but at the end of the day
you need to decide something as well I'm
going to put you on the spot right now
who is your favorite player in this
competition in this competition we have
the world champion we have ding Loren we
have Fabiano caruana from the US who is
leading the pasta it's my favorite from
Romania as well but I mean it's just
okay that's a good one that's a good one
because I like this history and I
spend a lot of time in business in
France as well obviously so um in two
two three I would say is my favorite
that's a great pick Hans uh thank you
very much for joining us my pleasure
guys thank you Christian thank you Hans
uh Ali Raza nice nice pick a lot of
people's favorites exactly again uh one
of these E4 E5 games I've got in front
of me
um
Wesley so as a position against Dr and
just uh here earlier uh this idea that
this Knight on C6 is kind of a little
bit of a problem piece if black could
just reach under the board and say let
me take away this night let me take away
the night on D2
and the chances of equality just go
really really high and uh how did Daniel
solve the problem of his Knight well he
used a maneuver
that Vladimir kramnik Anatoly karpov and
many many others you moved to E7 you
moved to G6 once the Knight gets to the
G6 Square
likewise it defends the pawn on E5 it
gives another measure of support to the
black king but more importantly it just
kind of gets out of the way so that
you're ready to play C7 and C6 in a much
volunteered challenge in the center with
the move D5 all of this is Theory as the
players are still
um no one I first saw the current
position I thought this was also Roy
Lopez because Bishop was on B5 right and
I thought it was very similar to alireza
ding game exactly but apparently they
started as an Italian game indeed yeah
the openness
yeah there you go Bishop C4 and yeah
because we also have A5 here just like
ding just played right very similar
position exactly and VAR uh What uh
games have caught uh your attention uh
in the opening thus far uh there are a
few few games here but in particular I
want to switch to this one game it's a
French defense yes sir okay so it's the
game between Anish giri and Richard
report and actually the same opening was
played in a world championship match
between Nepal and ding I was told and uh
report played a very rare move actually
in the opening here so in this position
so it's the standard
French defense the tarash variation so
Knight gf3 played and now C takes D4
Knight takes D4 Knight F6 and it takes
Z5 A6 this is a very rare move here the
main lines are queen takes D5 and Knight
takes D5 here but he played the move A6
and just to surprise Anish a little bit
here question bar did ding also play A6
in the championship uh I think it was I
don't think A6 was played uh in that
game here
Knight takes D5 was played in a world
championship game so A6 again this is a
preparation I think between Ding and
Richard and we see them uh playing the
football once again so now actually
Anish spent a little bit of time here
about four minutes here and decided to
play the move Knight D2 to F3 protecting
the Knight on D4 and now getting ready
to capture only six here so now you have
to capture back so Queen takes D5 and C4
is played actually uh it's amazing that
after only like eight moves we're in a
very rare position here only one game I
see in a database here after the move C4
Bishop D3 there are 17 games played here
Bishop E2 another six games but C4 is is
very rare only one game between two
grand masters from Russia here so the
queen is under attack here and we need
to understand where to put this queen
here so you have we have two options
here Queen A5 check is one option buddy
the best move is actually Queen d8
going back there and often times you
just want to put the queen on the eighth
here to make sure it's not going to be
under attack and if white is just
developing Bishop E2
we can just play Bishop D6
now let's say castle
and you can even play the move E5 here
questioning the Knight to the Knight
doesn't have any good squares to go to
you cannot go to B5 you cannot go to A5
and if you play something like Knight
Knight C2 or Knight Knight B3 let's say
Knight C2 and black doesn't have any
problems here Knight will go to C6
Bishop on F5 and very comfortable
position here for black and good control
of the center as well harmonious
development to be sure once again the
head-to-head matchups
whoa It's a real surprises in these Head
to Head uh Anish Gary with a very uh
dominant four wins no losses five draws
didn't see that one coming either
surprising
and as always we enjoy your comments
join the discussion uh challenge our
panel and send us your tweets right you
can send us your tweets using hashtag
super bad chess classic or you can tag
granchester you can also send your
questions uh via YouTube or twitch
channels on St Lucia's Club yes and we
enjoy a good challenge I must say I have
played the French defense
for decades and I have had this position
in my tournament practice and more or
less without too much discussion I've
always played Knight takes D5 and not
really thought anything beyond the fact
while I'm just recapturing the pawn
but when I saw the move a7a6 for the
first time and I'm seeing it literally
for the first time I'm sitting there
saying gosh I wonder why I never
considered that move there is so much I
like about this move because it
basically is asking a question for why
white would love just to play Bishop D3
castles Knight F3 and just get on with
business the problem with the immediate
Bishop F3 is now Queen takes D5 is
really brilliant a lot of times you
don't like to play the move Queen takes
D5 because Knight B5 really annoys you
and the problem is well Asics just stops
that no Queen takes D5 does all kinds of
good things and the move A7 A6 is just
so easy it's the main idea of A6 is to
present the position for you right and
prepare Queen takes and to play Queen
takes D5 so even I'm sure Anish was
actually even considering moves like
c2c3 anticipating that a queen takes D5
you might want to play Queen B3 I'm not
even sure about that but I love what
pharah was saying that uh once you go
Queen takes D5
Queen d8 Bishop D6 and let's again get
to the current position c2c4
if the Scandinavian was good for black
E4 D5
E4 would be a bad move
because the Scandinavian if it's good it
just kills E4 right and I always think
about that when I get to such positions
as
if I was to transpose into a
Scandinavian and again VAR is pointing
out that the engine prefers Queen d8 not
the move Queen A5 check but as a person
who respects the Scandinavian if you
could get away with a Scandinavian
and make equality I'm looking at this
position I don't think it's that bad for
black it looks like a pretty decent
Scandinavian to me anything like that
suggests trades trades trades I don't
think you should really put this as a
feather in your cap and say you know
I've got a big advantage of something I
don't feel that to be the case so I'm
not sure but I think Richie's opening
problems really bar they're behind him
and I appreciate Queen d8 mention Queen
A5 for a moment what what's wrong with
Queen A5 and does the engine consider
white to be better after Queen A5 check
no you're absolutely right Queen A5 is
another very good move here is second
best move in this position I think it's
just again pretty comfortably equalizes
the game I can show you a couple of
moves after three five so of course
sometimes we want to play the move Queen
E5 because also the tempo because we go
Queen d8 we can feel like we're losing
some Tempo here but Queen A5 actually
we're giving a check immediately so that
actually forces the move uh Bishop D2
right and now Bishop B4 right and here
uh you can take but also you can play
perhaps play the move A3 here computers
best move here is to play Bishop E2 the
choice is just to develop here after
Bishop E2 yeah uh simply Bishop takes D2
Queen takes D2 and now we exchange the
Queens
and here you can take with the king or
you can take with the Knight as well
both moves are just equal here so if you
take with a knight for example then I'm
seeing zeros behind absolutely yeah it's
all Zero's King is very comfortable on
E7 and then we can play the move B6
Bishop B7 and just complete the
development here I don't see any any
problems here for
by the way Richard has made a move and
he played Bishop before check right
Bishop before check played immediately
okay so I think guys this will probably
transpose into that line which Bishop D2
and then Queen A5 will be played so I
think this is forced now
Queen A5 and if you don't mind me being
a little bit of a past after the move
Bishop E2 VAR is Knight E4 disconcerting
at all is that a move that uh I mean you
don't really want to take on B4 and be
forced to move your king or something
like that right yes ah Knight B3 sorry
there is an ib3 here there is also
um apologies yeah you can also play A3
here but again even even here it just
shows how comfortable this Black's
position there it's not like you have to
play the only way to equalize you can
even play 94 you're still absolutely
fine here the answer so A3 for example
one of the lines is you play Knight
takes D2 right and if you take back with
the Knight I I will just go back Bishop
E7 and black has the pair of the Bishops
if you take on before this is a pawn
sacrifice here
if they check Bishop F3 Queen takes B4
and now white has to play the move Queen
D2 essentially sacrificing upon for some
initiative you cannot take on C4 this is
very important to note here because of
the move Rook C1 and now you're losing
your bishop and The Rook after so uh you
know you cannot capture more more than
one Pawn in this position so just after
Queen D2 uh Queen D6 is equal Queen B6
is another alternative so even here you
can win a pawn and just go Queen D6 and
you should be able to have a very
comfortable position
wonderful thank you for that VAR and in
just catching up on the game between
alireza and dingler in just as you
suggested Queen E7
and after a2a4 the move Knight C6 to V8
which again kind of reinforces what I
had mentioned that sometimes in these E5
E4 E5 structures a night on C6 is
misplaced and uh Knight yeah some things
preparation in this rule Lopez must be
outstanding outstanding because this was
Jan's main choice of opening in the
world championship range so I'm sure he
he knows everything there is to know
exact position here yeah a career if you
will with E4 E5 uh just catching I just
noticed that in every game we have E4
today
is that right yeah none of my openings
are being played oh no oh no
uh
yeah it's all e-force yes indeed uh just
catching up also on the game uh between
Duda and Fabi when we left it uh pretty
much the position was uh this one after
castles Bishop C2 chasing the night
night uh
from E4 back to C5 and you were
mentioning yourself Nancy if you get to
play Knight D5 for free like just make a
a soft move Knight to D2 for example I
kind of consider this a little bit of a
soft move Knight to D5 first of all
that's a Tempo against the rook and you
you said I I start liking Black's nights
and I'm with you on this one night comes
to F4 and you start looking at Deep
night dropping in a D3 and that's some
yeah so um
probably Knight D2 is not the theory how
is white supposed to get an advantage uh
as we see the head-to-heads a lot closer
by the way uh one win two losses I also
haven't played each other too many times
yet that's so many no
um
but yeah and Nice head to head
um VAR clear some cobwebs for us it's
early morning near in St Louis but after
the move Knight C5 what is what's the
Rook doing on E3 why how is white
supposed to get an edge well white
doesn't really have an edge okay that's
the that's the answer to that but the 92
is fine here Yasser you really need to
get that night developed and get to get
the Rook into the game as well here but
uh just the line that you guys were
looking at after 95 we can go a little
bit deeper here I think white actually
needs to play some precise moves to make
sure he doesn't get into trouble here
and again we see Fabiano still one hour
and 33 minutes so he is just very very
comfortable Duda already spent 20
minutes here so uh I yeah I think we
will see how the game will develop so
let's take a look at the 9bd2 first here
okay and uh and then there are some
other Alternatives here but let's just
look at this for 92 95 right now
attacking The Rook you don't want to put
the Rook only two because of Knight F4
Tempo so rookie one right and now Knight
F4 and now you have this thread of uh
Knight to D3 here and here white really
needs to put this Knight only forward
here try to exchange some pieces to make
sure he's he he's not actually worse
here so after 94
you can take Knight takes C4 Bishop B4
and here you have this interesting
option here you can try to go D5 attack
in the bishop like well Bishop Bishop
goes back to Bishop B1 is apparently a
better move than Bishop C2 I guess with
some ideas of Queen C2 later on and now
you play the move C5 you really need to
play the move C5 before white can put a
Pawn on B4 and control the C5 Square
here so this is quite important and now
after Queen C2
G6 and often times in this position this
Knight will just go back only six years
does that black just look better here to
my eyes yes yeah yeah as like an open
Sicilian where black has no problem oh
oh oh open not open Sicilian and open
Spanish yeah it shows zeros here in this
position
um after let's say queen D2 96 the line
goes on there by Queen H6 and uh
black can play here D4 or C4 I don't see
any problems here but I think there is
another alternative here let's take a
look here perhaps the move Knight G5
let's look at this here try to put
pressure immediately on H7 here this is
a very concrete move and perhaps this is
why Duda is thinking he's trying to see
if maybe he can play this move so the H7
Pawn is under attack and I think we have
only two options here G6 or H6 let's
analyze both of these moves so if H6 is
played there is a knight H7 move okay
attacking The Rook forcing the move Rook
E8 and after that there are some options
here Rook G3 for example or queen G4
here well this is much more exciting
from White's point of view because at
least in this position VAR The Rook on
E3 can become useful right now The Rook
is just a Target that gets pushed back
to the first Rank and the exact moment
that you're showing whether it's Queen
G4 or Rook G3 you start to get
enthusiastic right okay absolutely sorry
please continue Queen yeah let's go
let's go a couple of more moves in this
line here because this this could
actually happen I think Queen G4 now
we're trading Knight F6 checks so again
uh there are two options here Knight G6
is apparently also okay for black but
just a logical King HHS and more natural
move and here's Knight F6 sacrificing
the Knight attacking The Rook so
captures and now Rook G3 very concrete
idea just trying to give a Checkmate on
G7 and uh
Rook G8 and as we know a lot of these
lines end in a Perpetual or repetition
at some point and I think this is this
is one of them here Queen F4 or even
Queen H4 both moves I think they lead to
the same same positions here welcome
yeah Rook G6 now we need to play to
protect H6 and now wow Bishop G6 let's
say
Knight takes G6
Queen H6 tng8 if we take on F6 we're in
big trouble after Queen F6 here again we
don't have the development here so I
don't think white can really play for a
win here and Rook takes G6
captures Queen G6 uh it's it's very
dangerous to go to f8 because it takes
F6 there could be some Amazing Ideas so
that's why we play the move King h8 here
and here white needs to give a Perpetual
after it's really hard to believe that
King f8 is dangerous because I'm up two
pieces well I'm up a piece and the
Knights ready to jump back in to E6
defend G7 yeah let's take a look
actually if you take and as it just
takes and just 96 96 all right
yeah that's not fair yeah
um and the idea is I still have a temple
or two so Queen and then he actually
gains a little time with this check King
F7 and now we see the problem because
after this move F5 this is incredible
white tonight and Rook are not even
participating in India right it's a
queen and a Pawn on F6 and somehow
they're winning yeah and you're a piece
up at it and it's winning again uh
reminding everyone as we come into
today's round five we've got three
players at the top but Bobby has a plus
two three out of four as he's leading
the field uh Wesley and Richard a half a
point behind them that's a remarkable
variation and I liked you know if I was
in in um
I'd be playing Knight G5 because I don't
like Knight D2 Knight D5 Knight F4 but
that variation with Knight G5 and you
looked at one uh variation to be to be
clear and I thought H7 H6
um was the most challenging you know you
got to go Knight H7 but you also
mentioned there is a G7 G6 uh voice
let's take us through those uh lines if
you don't mind yeah so if G6 has played
this
then now the idea is to block it the
idea is to blockade this diagonal right
um now there is a move of E6
really yes and I'm surprised by that but
okay uh trying to capture on F7 so and
it gets really complicated now I think
uh
if we open up the f file let's say F
takes E6 F takes E6 here okay f366 then
I think just Knight takes E6 take it
back take back take back Rook takes E6
okay I'm confounded I would have thought
that that black is a happy camper that
after I don't know Knight F5 yeah
a white is uh slowly catching up on the
development and it looks like Black's
King is a little bit weak here and uh
small small Advantage here for white
some Bishop B3 ideas if you play Queen
D7 there is Bishop B3 for example here
Advantage white that's
okay I wow you know I I didn't I didn't
think but there are many other
Alternatives here so the G6 yeah yeah uh
after G6 even even I think there is a
move here Knight F5
no not not here I guess here's Queen G4
the idea was if you capture uh Queen
takes perhaps after the move G6
G6 E6 and here yes G6 E6 and here black
has Knight F5 which is the best option
here yeah to get the queen into the game
attack in the night here it takes upside
and also attacking on E3 here it takes
F7 right key G7 actually
I think that this position and this
lines are convincing me to never play
for E5
because I am not this is crazy
thank you for shaking the cobwebs this
early in the morning let's jump to
Bucharest and Christian can do more
damage than we're already experiencing
a little bit of an insight about this
position after both Bishops to C2 this
game has been played once before in the
database I'm sure Evolution probably
touched on this and that game continued
with F5 Fabiano played the move Knight
to C5 and at this point I was in the
playing hole just watching around and
then nepo came out stood up from his
board he was thinking about it and
started strolling around the playing
hole stopped at Fabiano's game and
started looking staring at Fabiano
incredulously he was like why did you
just play the move Knight to C5 isn't
the great gift just right there in the
position Bishop takes H7 aren't you
going to resign in the next couple of
moves for a second I was worried that
Fabiano just missed Bishop to H7 but of
course after uh King takes H7 this just
simply doesn't work because of one
simple factor in the position and that
is the Pawn on H3 if the pawn would be
on H2 then this would be game over uh
because after King to H6 for example of
course you're not going to go King to G8
because of Queen to H5 everybody knows
how the Greek gift sacrifice usually um
finishes and is going to finish you know
Checkmate for white
King to H6 the problem is you cannot get
the Rook from E3 to the H file with the
pawn on H2 that would be game over after
Queen to G4 follow it up with Rook to H3
the black king on H6 is going to get
checkmated right now on the age file you
only have one square from which you're
going to be able to Target my king and
that is the score H4 in the position
that's why there are a couple of Moves
In which I can defend against your
attack one of them and the most likely
uh the outcome in this game would have
been Knight to G6 and the game is over
uh White would resign because you have
absolutely no compensation for the
sacrificed piece you cannot get on the H
file you cannot Target miking on H6 and
you don't have a dark Square Bishop
either so very interesting moment right
now Fabiano was his usual uh confident
uh looking and nepo was just simply
incredulous but you guys were mentioning
Knight to G5 to my eyes this is not a
practical decision because you're just
simply burning all your Bridges after
the move H6 and you know that Fabiano
and I can tell you a little bit of an
inside Fabiano has analyzed this quite
tremendously so you don't want to enter
this type of trenches with a Fabiano
because after H6 Knight H7 Rook 28
there's no way back you have to find
your way out you start getting tempted
by ideas of Knight to F6 it does look
like you're getting very close to
checkmating the black king but it just
simply doesn't gather Fabiano with black
pieces probably knows exactly what he's
supposed to do and he would probably get
his way for example I was looking at
some lines Queen to G4 also makes a lot
of sense try to go Knight to F6 Knight
to G6 Bishop takes G6 and now no I'm not
going to touch that Bishop on G6 I just
used one piece I used my knight I gave
it away so that I block the G file so
that now you don't have Knight to F6 uh
check and my G7 Pawn is not pinned I
mean it doesn't make any sense this is
as you guys called it alien chess in
this position you don't want to play
this when you don't know exactly what
you're doing when you haven't analyzed
this position at home and I can tell you
from duda's expression uh he hasn't
analyzed this at home he was kind of
bewildered about what's happening in the
position right now I can tell you what
he's thinking he's thinking to pull the
brakes how do I pull the brakes how do I
make a draw in the position and that's
why he played the move Knight bd2 well
probably the safest way or at least what
could be the safest way for white right
now is try to get the night weave or
exchange a bunch of pieces go into the
end game and make a draw but you know
after Knight to D5 the Knight lands on
F4 maybe on D3 as well this is not that
easy so definitely this is the mindset
that I'm seeing from these two players
right now Duda he got caught out of the
opening Fabiano had tremendous
preparation I took the right decision
now not playing the move Knight to G5
that was a very dangerous bridge burning
move don't play that play the move
Knight bd2 get the Knight to E4 exchange
some pieces and try to steer the game
into the end game and make a draw as
white Fabiano probably is half happy
with a draw because he knows he got
quite a significant Edge in knowledge in
this position not on the board
objectively because the position is
still very balanced but in knowledge
he's analyzed this position at home dude
that probably hasn't so this is
um the dynamic that I'm seeing from
these two players as of right now thank
you Christian you know one of the joys
of doing commentary and broadcasting
Nancy is we get to sacrifice the
material and if it doesn't work
that move Bishop takes H7 check is it a
dead end because you know those
sacrifices can you know can be really
awesome and I was listening to what
Christian was saying and the fact that
nepo himself kind of stopped and said
are you allowing this really you know
your king is going to walk the plank
right Bishop dates stage seven check
King takes H7 Knight G5 check
King H6 only move and as a Christian was
explaining if there if that pound were
on H2 it'd be check and made Queen G4
Knight G6 there's no follow-up to this
position I was looking at Rook G3 just
for a second to threaten Knight takes F7
uh with mate I saw the move Queen E8 I
stopped but you know whenever you see
the King on H6 you know
it's a hunt
was there opportunity absolutely no I
think it just doesn't work it doesn't
look like minus six right now just and
the move is Queen D7 here I think it's
even very D7 a very important move
because I see that you're setting up the
Knight F7 move right with the queen G6
and uh it's it's a really clever idea
but just the queen queen D7 is very very
concrete because now you're trying to
exchange the Queens right and once the
Queens come off the board the game will
be over here clear and uh and Knight F7
now will be met by the move Queen F7
just simply protecting the G6 Knight
there's another alternative here it's
more complex here but actually it's also
winning here instead of Knight G6 you
can even just play the move Knight F5 if
you want to just simply uh you know pick
up the G5 Knight next because now The
Rook is hanging and G5 is saying and
also you secured the H4 Square so the if
you play Queen takes F5 Queen takes G5
this is another alternative it just
shows that uh black doesn't even have to
play the only move 6 there is also
possibility with Knight F5 and simply
Bishop H7 sacrifice doesn't work and as
mentioned Knight D2 was do this Choice
let's just uh drop back in on uh the
game between nepo and mvl uh big big
heavyweight Clash going on and that was
the
c2c3 a lot of conversation yeah and okay
mvl was a bit taken aback took some time
did play the move D7 D5 uh main line
Knight A3 uh
Knight C4 this certain Echoes of the
Richie Rapport game as well in this
right the queen is on D5 sorry I think
on uh since I I've played this with
black before on Knight E3 I haven't seen
A6 I thought the main move was just
dropped we went back Queen d8 I think
that's the main alternative yes yeah A7
A6 if you don't get uh
uh forked with the move Knight C4 to B6
uh
you you may regret playing against six
right okay 97 A4 okay after 97 black is
ready to play B5 A4 B6 and the players
have reached I'm gonna say still we're
in theoretical Waters a slightly better
end game for white more pleasant
position for sure you've got the queen
side majority and it's not easy for
black to use a central majority but okay
uh
sometimes you just you you don't have a
good idea against the open Sicilian and
here's the surprising lifetime results
between these two players right nvl has
six wins
one loss and 10 draws and one of the
wins yes sir you probably will remember
this so like slimfield Cup last round
yeah and we are one in a sicilian and
secured the first place in a single cup
and won the tournament thanks to that
enormous Victory uh I I've never seen
mvl have such a great smile as he had at
the end of that particular game so
Knight D2 okay we'll keep an eye on that
dingler in so back just for a moment to
Geary rapper Game because last time we
looked we were talking about this end
game where Richard could have taken on
D2 and we said black has no issues
exactly we like this position Bishop
takes D2 he decided to keep the Queens
on the board Queen C7
and on each respond with Queen G5 right
fortunate castle Yeah gifts me the pawn
and Bishop B2 so
do we think White's going to attack on
the king side
uh it's one of those positions where you
could say right back here when Richie
decided to keep the Queens on the board
and I agree I think Queen takes D2
um very practical decision for those of
for those players who really like
Sicilians
they're probably sympathetic to keeping
the queen on the board in other words
once you have your Pawn on A6 and you're
not being harassed by Knight B5 and or a
dark Square Bishop the queen on c7s
pretty darn good you know it just it's
kind of lurking and maybe on okay just
let me just play some bad moves for
white okay just for a moment P6 uh
castles uh Bishop B7 and I want to just
make a bad move how can I make a bad
move yeah something like this right
suddenly this queen on C7 you know a
move like Knight G4 kind of Might rock
your world I'm I'm trying to make some
bad moves to show that the queen on C7
can play some Mischief on this uh
Sicilian style not to mention that
sometimes the C4 Pawn could be
potentially weak after a bishop takes
from White's point of view the queen on
C7 is let's say nicely hidden away
what's widescreen doing uh one thing the
White Queen doesn't want to do is become
an open Target along the D file like
castles castles Rook d
you know and you start to say well where
should I put my queen you know do I put
my queen on some silly Square so I think
the idea wasn't so much to start an
attack with the McQueen Chief five and
so much as it was to kind of like maybe
get out of the way yeah and maybe again
to offer another
type of Queen trade with Queen
G35 or queen E5 maybe
um
now having said all of that I still have
this overall sense that Richie's happy
like that black has traded off one set
of minor pieces he doesn't have any
Targets he has pretty decent development
you can see B6 Bishop B2 97 or
conversely how do I develop this bishop
Rook E8 E5 yeah but more I'm looking at
this position I'm coming up with ideas
for white okay please uh I think White's
going to Castle short and play B4 and C5
and try to let's get it let's go space
on the Quinn side right okay uh Bishop
E2 say I I develop okay so 97 right yes
uh Castle okay and again I look at my
bishop and I say you got you you're
naughty you have to get into the game
say before okay you've got your space
life is good
Bishop B7 and a rook C1 Rook
presumably this one okay Rook C1 and
let's say
am I afraid of C5
I shouldn't be afraid of C5 because I've
got 94 kind of ideas okay rookie eight
I'm still not loving the queen on G5 not
at the moment no no not yet not yet yeah
and I don't know my my intention is to
play Rook to d8 complete my development
and just ask you are you going to play
C5 are you going to play for A5 bar jump
in and tell us what game has caught your
eye yeah let's take a look at this game
here one thing I see uh that it's a
little bit different we see uh dayak is
actually playing very fast in this game
so he's got actually more time than
Wesley saw here and I wanted to go over
some of these lines here so I think we
left off around
around here uh so A5 was played so and
we continue now uh H3
Bishop B5 again often times after Bishop
B5 white is considering to take on C6
and play the move d4 here
Bishop A7 plate Knight E7 and now the
idea is to transfer the Knight on G6 as
you mentioned the answer and now Knight
F1 same thing white wants to bring the
Knight to G3 and Bishop D7 played trying
to exchange the Bishops here and uh here
we see the move Bishop D3 another
alternative here was to play the move A4
to try to secure the B5 square and if
you take for example I think white would
be happy to take back with the pawn here
and open up the rook and put pressure on
a fire but once they decided to retreat
with the bishop here on D3 and they're
not so much Theory anymore in this
position so players aren't playing on
their own Here and Now B5 played trying
to gain some space on the queen side and
A4 by Wesley actually sacrificing the
pawn temporarily and now trying to
create some weaknesses here deak
actually took because if you played the
move before it will be I think slightly
worse in this position the the
especially the C4 Square could be very
useful at some point for the bishop to
go to and also maybe Knight will go
there and attack the pawn on A5 here so
after Knight G3 well white is a little
bit better here BC we take C3 for
example this A5 Pawn could be a Target
so Derek decided to take on a force
and uh I think this is the current
position after that Wesley just played
the move Bishop C2 so just gave up the
pawn and now he wants to capture the
pawn back Bishop A4 and if he manages to
do that this A5 pound will be weak and
uh I see a very slight maybe very slight
Advantage for white but once again the
fact that the ACT is playing fast he's
not behind on the clock is
a good sign for him for this game
wow I've okay I'm once again I'm
mystified I'm one of those uh players
who always likes a great Pawn structure
and for me
deox decision to play B5 B5 takes A4 and
permanently I mean what else can I say
if it's not permanently ruin your queen
Side Pawn structure because it it
strikes me that white is you know an
overwhelming favorite right frankly just
to win this Pawn back on a four Once
white has recaptured the pawn on A4
which I think is an inevitability
there's going to be a weak Pawn on A5
there's going to be a weak Pawn on C7
and why white doesn't have a long-term
Advantage is beyond my understanding I
I'm and I'm looking at vars add chess
engine and it's just a slight slight
slight slight advantage and I'm sitting
there going I really like your structure
let me show you how I give you on the
term massage one thing you ask her
perhaps is there's still some Dynamics
in the position here we can go maybe a
couple of more moves to shoot I think
black is going to try to put some
pressure on the center so let's see here
okay
rookie eight first yeah this is a
logical Move Get The Rook into the game
and some it's in some lines you want to
take on D4 and put pressure on this Pawn
here so white will have to play the move
Knight G3 because if you pick
immediately then after the capture it's
captured it takes D4 and then you're
gonna be dropping this E4 Pawn here I
agree so you you need to play the move
Bishop Knight to G3 first agree to
secure the E4 pawn and now here's for
example Bishop B6
gift meet the part yeah you take the
pawn you should pay for Bishop takes A4
Queen A4 okay and the bishop on B6 is
well placed because now the A5 Pawn is
protected and here
Play the movie with Queen D7 here trying
to trade Quincy if the Queens come off
the board then black will have the
opportunity to play the move A4 and
Advance this pawn and if you take on D7
Knight takes D7
um that that's being too compliant VAR
first of all there is a move Knight H5
after Queen D7 that there's also simply
Queen C2 yes let's take a look at the
Knight H5 for example if you play Knight
H5 this is a very nice move because now
if Queen takes A4 we have this in
between on F6 takes back and Rook takes
A4 and white is white is a little bit
better here only a little only a little
bit oh my gosh I'm thinking this is
monstrously better for white look at the
structure okay yeah a little bit better
but after Knight H5 black can play Queen
E6 okay Queen E7 for example and now the
Knight is uh hanging here if you go back
Knight G3 I go back Queen D7 and if you
take Queen takes F6 right and again we
see some pressure still on the force
some pressure on a file and thanks to
this Dynamics I think block is just okay
in this position
wow okay I'm scratching my head here in
St Louis I gotta tell you turning our
attention to Ali Reza and ding Loren
because again A Clash of the Champions I
want to put it that way grantchester
Champion
defending uh grantchester or Champion
alireza farouzia against the new world
champion from China dingler in and we
left it after this move Knight B8 h2h3
just a kind of useful move taking
control of the G4 Square
limiting ideas of both Bishop G4 and
Knight G4 as well the pawn on H3 nine
times out of ten turns out to be useful
Bishop back to E2 the bishop actually is
in the way this Knight is anxious to go
to the C4 square if we leave if we do it
immediately as desirable as this might
be putting pressure on the E5 Pawn C7 C6
kind of ruined the day you know like why
did we trap our own Bishop so Bishop
Bishop did his job on B5 it did uh it
might be a to provoked uh Rook E1 again
a very useful move we always teased
Vladimir kramnik we said When Vladimir
didn't know what to do he put his work
on Ewok and The Rook is very useful
there your idea is to play Knight F4
next Knight F1 the flexibility of even
Bishop F1 or I think the Knight is going
to C4 mainly I think the Knight is going
to go to C4 swing maybe either t uh E3
and to F5 in which case if the Knight
we're on F5 The Rook on E1 kind of makes
a little sense as it opposes uh the the
queen uh rookie1 and we're caught up to
the play players and uh if you were to
evaluate this position as we get ready
for our break what does the engine tell
us zero zero zero get out of here you
know you're off my Christmas A-list I
know unfortunately that's what we see in
a lot of these positions today yes sir
just it's very symmetrical position I
actually have a lot of experience
playing this type of positions from the
uh the perk defense I get sometimes and
uh right
um yeah it's Knight can go to C4 and
then you have this option always from C4
to jump into E3 try to go to F5 and
Define but black is just very very solid
here we can look at couple of moves here
how black should play after the move
rookie one so one idea here is actually
we see that this B6 move is is playable
here with the idea to put a bishop on B7
to Target the E4 Pawn so say Knight C4
Knight C4
and now we can play the move H6 first
maybe to control the G5 Square
and also prevent the Bishop from coming
to G5 now we need a square for this
bishop here and uh engine is suggesting
Bishop D2 I'm not sure about this but I
guess at some point the idea is to
prepare the move before and now Bishop
B7
attacking the pawn on e4 now Bishop F1
yeah that's the point of the move rookie
one often times you put the bishop on F1
and this way actually you solve the
problem of defending the E4 Pawn right
and queen E6 there's a good move here
because now you have this diagonal to go
back in case so before you can always go
back Bishop E7 or Bishop f8 tier and
again just a symmetrical position and uh
it looks solid looks it looks very solid
for black no problems for the world
champion
thank you vard as we prepare for our
break we gotta check in on our favorite
chess shop Q Boutique and let's see what
they're offering today I think here's
something you're going to love a unique
concave board crafted from Walnut Maple
Woods that feature Chessmen with
weighted rounded bathrooms that wobble
freely pieces feature Chrome accents on
the king and queen and available at Q
Boutique St louis.com I don't know those
wobbly pieces boy that kind of throw me
off a little bit but that's quite on
that board before and it's surprised and
how pieces do not fall yeah very hard to
make them fall okay well that's good for
Blitz I guess uh as we prepare for break
we have this is special we asked the
players their thoughts about artificial
intelligence
[Music]
as chess players we've had a symbiotic
relationship with computers for quite a
long time are you using the new
technology chat GPT all these new
artificial intelligence solutions that
we have right now
yeah which is players use AI to change I
think it's an open Secrets yes and the
neural network is basically a must for
today's Grandmaster
it was Revolution like some five years
ago I think that Alpha zero beats I
side back then in London that was very
unexpected and very big since engine is
like I got I mean it cannot be beaten
and here it comes some AI you know who a
day before didn't know which is rules
and just smashed smashed the stockfish
so after that I mean
everyone was really like
fascinated I guess by it and also was
looking for ways to improve their chests
yeah I mean for me personally like it's
all for zero and and just a little AI
stuff was um as a whole is of course it
changed the game of just the way we
played compared a few years ago when it
came but I believe it's just sort of a
test phrase if you will a convenient 2
version of what's going to happen
outside of Chess in the real world and I
believe since Justice you know to me
it's a very important game but it's just
a game right there are much more serious
issues in the world so I believe chess
is showing the day I can come up with
serious unexplored ideas in a game that
people have been playing for for you
know ages AI can really be a game
changer it's still progressing a lot we
don't know after one or two year what
will happen but I'm sure that if we can
use it in a good way it can be
beneficial for chess and as it was for
instance a stockfish when it came out
everybody thought it would be dead the
chest but it also grow dishes so we can
learn more and we study more but I'm
very optimistic chess and AI together
it's a very good combination computers
really revolutionize the game
um and so players as a player you need
to adjust be ready for
uh everything but at the same time I
think that computers can only really do
so much in the game because
as a player you can your brain can only
take so much you can only memorize so
many lines
so in that regarding chess has become
more difficult than the old days I
personally my opinion I don't think that
the computer can change the game of
radical some people think it can but
I think young people still play the game
there's obviously a lot more Theory
nowadays than before yeah the
um AI has sort of
I started with chess pretty much
I think the big breakthrough was when
Alpha zero was built and that that's
also you know gave confidence to a lot
of researchers
as I've heard to just you know to see
the potential and now building on that
there are so many tools already in the
making and uh I'm sure within the chess
uh within the Chess World there are many
things you can utilize it for you can
definitely see um
potential in some sort of AI tutoring it
seems like it's lacking you know a power
to answer these specific questions
and for now and it seems like you know
the engines we have no stockfish with
Alpha zero when they when it came out
there's the best AIS that I know to
answer these specific questions so
foreign
professionals and I suspect it won't be
anytime soon but I could be wrong yeah I
think over China
uh sometime it was and they will combine
Maybe
GPT or sell something else with the
stock fish and a little zero or
something yeah and it would be quite
quite useful too but I guess we are not
at this point but you know things are
developing quickly
itself like we don't
like the language learning model doesn't
have
much relevance at the moment for chess
but still like we've seen the the
computer Revolution it continues like
computers are super super strong in
chess and and I think that we're going
to see that like across the board not
just in chess but in everyday life
technology is going to continue to uh to
to
expand and who knows what will happen I
mean hopefully more good things and bad
things well you never know but in terms
of Chess it's definitely changed the
game quite a lot
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super bed our
standings coming in today's play messy
right we have a soul leader Fabiano
caruana with plus two score nice
followed closely by Wesley so and
Richard rapid with plus one just a half
a point behind a lot of players trailing
at 50 percent and let's jump into round
five pairings all right we have some
very exciting matchups today nepo
against MBL right do die against
Carolina
heavyweight so against diac and giri
against Rockford well let's jump right
into it because as we were on our break
we were talking about the game of nepo
and mvl and the fact that first of all
we had this all happened with c2c3
Sicilian not exactly Eon style and yet
he's played every single move
perfectly according to our chess engines
if you will at that and he's done it in
a record
breaking time fast so much so there's an
hour difference almost an hour
difference between MBO and nepo uh tell
me about that so it has has Jan gained
time from the starting uh from the
starting moments he started for 90
minutes he lost some time because he was
walking around right he's got to come
back and he's got to write down his move
so here's hour and 24 minutes VAR uh
it's so intimidating regardless whether
you're playing at the club level you
know the 2800 level when you have a
player an opponent is playing instantly
and frankly playing all the best moves
you start to ask yourself what hasn't he
prepared you start to get really really
worried tell me about this position and
as MBL fallen into prep I think he's
actually in the Nepal is playing very
very accurately yes sir evaluation is
still pretty small here but the
difference is 50 minutes already on the
clock and one thing we know mvl is
actually a pretty fast player himself
he's one of the very best rapid and
Blitz players in the world but the fact
that he's spending so much time it shows
I think that he's just not comfortable
with the position here and um and yeah
he's definitely intimidated because you
know this could be some really good
preparation from Nepal here but let's
take a look what is the best thing black
can do in the current position here so
the last move here was Knight B3 to D2 I
think he's trying to uh protect the
Knight on C4 here and one of the options
here is to try to play A5 here
try to control the B4 Square
in this case now
white can play the move Knight E3
putting pressure on the bishop
and if the bishop goes back then this
other Knight now comes in on C4
and now putting pressure on B6
H6 for example
and you can even play the move H3
nothing concrete here but it's just a
little bit unpleasant now with this B6
Pawn being fixed like this a little bit
easier also to play for the white pieces
here you can play perhaps Rook 8.
okay it looks like there is a move there
is a move here guys rook fc8 and this is
an innocuous this is an inaccuracy
because now white has a very strong A5
right now you are if you take you're
always going to be much worse in a
position like this because A6 spawn is
terribly weak and these pawns are very
very strong so this is a big Advantage
for white and of course he's thinking to
play the move B5 here but now Knight B6
forking The Rook so you have to take
Pawn takes B6 and now the a file is open
A6 Pawn is very weak and it's not easy
to win this B6 Pawn
and if you play Bishop C5
to attack the pawn on B6
and now this is a very interesting
moment here C4 crucial here to attack
the bishop
and if B takes C4 right
Knight takes C4
a line continuous Bishop takes C4 again
if you take back with the bishop after
Bishop B6 block is absolutely fine but
now you play B7 forking the Rooks giving
up the bishop only two here and after
the capture here Rook d c one wow looks
are forked and now you're threatening
that the move Rook takes C5 and it looks
like at the end of this line white is
going to be up exchange the best move is
94 here
now Bishop E3
I like how white has Pawn on B7 and
never captures any game yeah he's not
even capturing it right Rook bc8
takes on C8
Rook takes C8 and after the B4 we will
get into an end game like this bishop B5
Bishop C5 and
a nice Advantage for white still a lot
of work needs to be done to convert a
position like this
wow quite the variation and through the
magic of Television we don't like this
move Rook C8 and we can see
after mvl plays the move
so that's a egg it's hard for me to
tell until it has 34 minutes and Nepal
hour 24. wow what a huge difference and
again that that invitation to play a4a5
but it's not that obvious all these
lines VAR was just showing us no not at
all I mean calculating yeah it's not
easy to play this move A5 it actually
looks like uh now the evaluation is
actually jumping it's going back and
forth and uh still shows the white is
better but A5 is absolutely necessary
here to have a disadvantage here the
question is if nepo knows this if he
plays this instantly
now this is going to be a really really
bad sign for mvl but if he hasn't played
yet
and he played he played 93 a lot more
cautious because you do play A5 B5
Knight B6 that's a one-way Bridge
whatever whatever you're writing
whatever long tactical winded variation
there is you're not coming back after A5
B5 Knight E3 not bad either
absolutely yeah it's a Tempo against the
bishop attacking the bishop Bishop goes
back on C6 and now the other night jobs
to C4 yeah and we got the D6 Square to
work with also pressure on B6 still some
problems here for black here it's a long
ways away here from trying to equalize
this game here so there's king f8 move
but it's it's hard to play moves like
this you kind of want to have a concrete
plant here but nothing you can do
immediately B5 is always going to run
into the move Knight A5 for example so
you cannot do that and if this Pawn was
on A6 it would be a lot easier to play
this position for by with the pawn on A6
you have this problem of the Pawn on B6
again engine wants to play this move A5
and now we see the main idea is just to
prevent white from playing this move A5
as well and prevent the move B4 but
that's that's that's we see this move A5
uh being suggested here early at the
start of the round we got ourselves all
excited by the game that was going on
between our turn
leader uh Fabi against Duda Duda with
the white piece is now under normal
circumstances we'd be saying you know
heavyweight match
but because Duda got off to such a bad
start we're sitting there saying well
you know can Bobby potentially increase
his lead and uh we like the move at 98.
pardon me 95 attacking The Rook The Rook
drops back Knight F4 and we were saying
okay on a good day we get to plant the
night on D3 we're really happy campers
but some forcing moves 94
a suggestion uh Vara had made
trading off some pieces Christian also
mentioned that that I can feel that pop
is extremely well prepared and maybe
right maybe it's time to exchange some
pieces neutralize the position rookie
eight b2b4 uh trying to force those
trades now a moment ago
we were looking at a position with
Knight takes E4 Bishop takes E4 D5 the
bishop was coming back to B1 and we said
to ourselves well don't allow the move
B4 play C5 but because the pawn is now
already on uh B4
right here
um
is there an alternative for Fabi not to
go into that uh trade probably we're
going to take yes we're probably going
to take yes and thanks to the fact that
this Rook is in a pin we're not worried
about an immediate uh capture we'll go
back on G6
excuse me and try to capture other Pawn
on E5
I I hate to call it early like this but
I do see a lot of Trades taking place
and the pieces literally getting
vacuumed off the boardvar I think well
again I don't want to jinx it but draw
kind of feels a little bit inevitable in
this game of hobbies absolutely with
accurate play I think it's just uh very
likely yeah we'll see some trades occur
there are some interesting lines here I
want to show you here please so for
example here if you play the move
so we expect Fabi to take after the move
before right you don't really want to
retreat because then white can take on
D6 so I think we will see this
moves played and here if you play the
move Knight G6 I think there is a chance
white might be tiny bit better after the
move Queen E2 here really because if you
take everything only five right
so let's say you take munch munch munch
munch munch
and now the queen is actually active
only five here and there's uh targeting
C7 and also A6 spawn is a little bit
weak and after the move rookie one you
will be able to control the e-file I
still think with accurate accurate play
Black should be able to equalize but
again a little bit easier to play for y
The Rook on V8 is also it needs couple
of moves to come back into the game here
uh like let's say H6 is the best option
rookie one Queen D6
and even end game like this maybe white
can try to play a little bit because of
the the weaknesses of A6 and D6 uh but
uh but Fabiano can play uh better all
right so let's go back here and in this
position
instead of uh
yeah rookie Forge
so here he can play the move D takes E5
and now Knight takes E5
and here a very strong move is Knight
takes H3 check
so if you capture
Queen G5 check if we block it with the
queen there is uh Rook takes C5 same
thing if you block it with the uh Rook
Queen takes C5 as well 94 then we're
dropping The Rook only four here so King
H1 is the only move
and now Rook takes E5
and F4 only move
now there are a few options Queen H4 or
queen F5 it will lead to the same
position alien queen H3 check King G1
and now becomes clear that you cannot go
to F1 because Queen F4 check will pick
up your Rook so you have to go back on
H1 and this will lead to a
Perpetual here after Queen G3 so this
will be the most accurate way for
Fabiano to equalize the game the perfect
game perfect play a lot of work for the
draw but that move Knight takes H3
forcing a prepaid wow uh Mazel Tov uh
great stuff going on there I want to
draw our attention to this game Geary
versus Robert okay
with a half a point out of first hoping
for something good to happen we left it
here please Anish offered another coin
exchange so Bishop E2 rookie eight and
this is where I was saying there's two
ways for black to solve the problem of
the bishop Ian Shadow the bishop or
aspire to play the movie E5 and this is
where you were about to say the queen
trade was offered yes Henry she said no
again no again no one couldn't be six
okay uh and white plays B4 gift meet the
pawn B4 which I like but white hasn't
castled yet so that's making me a little
bit nervous okay so now I was thinking
Ken black uh attacked the queen with
Tempe let's say absolutely B27 let's do
it and that is a Tempo and where do we
put the queen I feel like wherever you
go I have another Temple move okay so
let me just ditch G3 okay okay I I know
85 E4 I know what you're talking about
as far as the Tempe move I was hoping to
get it win it back if you will with them
also Knight E4 option I don't know if
it's if it achieves anything nice four
okay now I've got to move my queen again
you are you are bouncing me about I will
uh give you that but is it meaningful at
the moment I'm not sure
yes I can play Knight D2 F6 or I can
play Knight C3 both look interesting
Knight C3 that tickles my it's
like will you stop harassing me so I can
just kind of provoking Bishop D3 you you
certainly are I've tried defend H7 then
E5 E4 is coming on your agenda yeah but
it depends on how you defend
uh like G6 you're kind of inviting my G5
yeah okay fair uh because otherwise I
was going to say you know no your knight
on C3 makes a little bit of a strange
impression
um
it's not trapped it's not trapped but
it's close
okay I'm a little bit afraid of E5 okay
so forgive me that uh
there's something a little bit
artificial about both players play here
but uh the fact that I'm not castled I'm
with you I'm a little bit nervous can we
go back for a moment uh to the current
position Knight D7 I I started with
Queen G3 did you anticipate bad as being
my best move or with something else or
something about Queen E3 just to offer a
coin exchange again after E5
like like E5 night night F5 or something
and another queen trade huh
um by the way played Knight G4 instead
of Knight D7
you know just when you think you
understand chess a move like Knight G4
really shakes you up to the core and
asks you you know what is the meaning of
life what is my purpose Knight G4 of our
uh did the computer engines like this
move has that got a seal of approval uh
second best move here I was also a
little bit surprised to see because uh
same thing as you right yes I think you
kind of develop your pieces here right
and I would be you know I'm already a
little bit concerned with the queen on
B6 you know I would have liked to have
the queen on C7 Fawn on B6 and to get
the bishop out but this Knight G4 is
again just not really developing the
Knight on B8 I was looking at the line
with Knight bd7 and it's very
interesting actually there too uh but
let's look let's take a look at Knight
G4 now here Knight G4 attacking the
queen here so the best move here is
Queen G3 okay retrieving and also
putting pressure on the net and now his
idea is definitely to play the move E5
here clear remove the Knight from D4 and
also open up the diagonal for the bishop
here so Knight B3
best move
and Wyatt really wants to cancel and
then play the move H3 here sure and uh
Knight C6 for there is a knight H6 move
here but again it's a it's a very
strange way of playing Knight H6 with
the idea Knight F5 so let's say he plays
Knight C6
more logical more logical yeah so you
play C5 attacking the queen
Queen to C7
and now
you can Castle here another option is to
play the move Knight fd2
the point is you attacked the Knight and
also that gives you the option to bring
the queen to C3 and in the long run this
Knight would be very well placed here
with because you can play Knight C4 and
go to the D6 Square so strategically I
think this is a little bit risky for
black this position because if white can
Castle Consolidated position get the
Knight on C4 and D6 I see some chances
for him to have an advantage here
[Music]
there's some very strange artificial
play but like nobody's getting uh
punished for it just uh checking and
once again on the game of Fabi we do
have
that trade and it might happen how how
deep is father's preparation while
Christian kind of gave us an Insight
when he said I mean he a Christian who
worked has worked with Fabi quite a
number of years in fact and now they're
doing their podcasting together uh
c-squared check it out everybody
um and he said Fabi has worked really
really hard on this particular opening
and you look at the current position on
the board you go wow it kind of it's
pretty balanced
um you know material wise I can imagine
that for example after Knight G6 okay
Vara was mentioning the line that
imperceptibly white might get some kind
of an edge in a straight major piece
ending it's a shocking uh idea H3 check
uh sorry that black has a force
Perpetual are we going to see that like
why I mean you know and I don't know
yeah that would be
how again how deep is the prep King H1
Rook takes what's more impressive is
that he remembers it all yeah exactly
because we can all prepare with our
engines but right to actually remember
everything at the board exactly so a lot
of uh people just don't understand how
very very difficult it is sometimes to
play your opening novelty uh and here as
VAR was mentioning you can't walk to the
F1 Square because that's your rook and
there goes the game you have to go to
the H1 square and this is the Perpetual
check so imagine there you are you're
you're sitting there saying to yourself
I'm going to be playing dingler in in
the sink fill cup and I'm going to have
the white pieces on I'm going to have
the black pieces and you look at dings
repertoire and you drill deeply and you
find this beautiful novelty oh this is
great this is going to bring you glory
and success and you just can't wait to
spring it on them and then you notice
that in the rapid and Blitz tournament
somebody plays your novelty against the
opponent that you had prepared so it's
one thing first of all you've got to
work really hard you've got to find some
great ideas that really catch somebody
off guard then you got to deliver and
it's oftentimes other people get the
opportunity before you do and you're
like no
when you get lucky in the sense that
your opponent walks into your
preparation yes and then you can't
remember the line
okay that is worse that is worse that
that has happened that happens very
often yeah so where we think that the
current position that Duda has after
Knight takes E5 May well have been in
the laboratory uh of uh Fabi and that
fabby's preparation could very well
include Knight takes H3 Perpetual check
will he remember the whole line or not
that's I meant he wants to the question
test do that and see if
he can get an advantage somewhere here I
doubt it though yeah well we'll see that
would be a big risk unnecessary risk
what has caught your attention uh VAR uh
let's switch to this game here and nepo
against mvl and actually he has to find
the next move here to have an advantage
here so very important moment here
Bishop B5 is the key move here uh to be
able to get an advantage let's take a
look at some of the lines now after this
move so if we go back uh last few moves
so we left off around here Knight DC4 A5
was played by nvl Knight to D6 Knight is
very active and annoying here so he
decided just simply to take
Bishop D6 now Knight C5 the pawn on A4
is under attack and you don't have the
move B3 so you have basically two
options in this position either to take
on C5 which will give you a perhaps a
very small Advantage here but you can
play like this as well and then play the
move Bishop B5 right since the A5 Pawn
is weak C5 is a little bit weak you will
have very very small Advantage here as
well in this position but the best move
here is to keep the bishop on D6 and
play the move Bishop B5 immediately
right now uh black will most likely
capture
okay on B5 and then you take back
with with the pawn again the B6 is the
main problem for blocking this position
and at some point we have Knight C4
Knight B6 ideas as well 98 would be a
logical move to try to remove this
Bishop from D6 but in fact we can
actually leave it there for now and play
even a move like F3 or King F1 just
bring the king closer to the center here
because if you capture the bishop on D6
then Rook takes D6 now attacking the
pawn on B6 and this will be a real
problem because very difficult now to
protect this Pawn Rook AB8 will lead
into the move Knight C4 putting pressure
on B6 and if you play the move Knight E4
attacking the rook and the Knight on C4
there is simply this move
there are two moves here you can play
Rook B6 but also you can play the move
Rook C6
extremely strong yeah and now uh this
would be a very very big Advantage here
Rook takes C6 Pawn takes Rook C8 Knight
B6 X6 and again the fact that you don't
have your Luft is going to play a very
big role here because Rook takes F5 will
threaten the move Rook 8 and white has a
big Advantage here so Bishop B5 is
necessary here to go for a bigger
Advantage but Bishop C5 will give him
some small Edge as well here
nice uh variation therefore uh the
counter-intuitively as you were
analyzing I was looking at something
very similar to what you were showing
um
and that was with the move Bishop B5
like you said Bishop takes B5 a takes B5
and when you played Knight E8 uh it's
not that I'm anxious to give up my
bishop or anything like that it's just
that I love
the control of the open D file
and for that reason I found myself drawn
to this counter-intuitive idea of
capturing now you never want to play
Pawn takes seeding me a password
and you know that is just really
devastating the night on C4 is simply
huge you have to take with a rook and
you would do so proudly until you stop
and look at the think about the position
just a moment or two after the move C4
at first you you're you're saying to
yourself oh I'm doing fine with black
but look at another move or two first of
all I do have a thread of B4 so likely
you're going to move the rook and this
is why I said I was kind of drawn to
this idea because I do have control over
the open file I'm kind of the first to
establish make a claim you know look at
look at this and and if you ever play
Knight F6 you know I'll drop back and I
will tickle the pawns so I do feel that
Jan has emerged with the better ending
maybe it's not that great but it just
feels like a long term something
something and he has played B5 and he
has played Bishop B5 Bishop B5 play guys
and uh uh Nepal is playing very well and
he's got an hour and 10 minutes mvl on
29 minutes here and uh don't forget mvl
lost yesterday so you know right yeah
he's trying to right I mean they're both
a bit vulnerable at the moment Nepal is
kind of like um
I'm finding myself getting interested in
the game suddenly
nice
which game haven't we uh checked in a
little bit let's see Wesley so and uh
deox position Daniel dayak uh I thought
the decision to play B5 by Daniel B7 B5
B5 takes A4 to be
a bad one I can't say it any better than
that I just love white structure even
though I agree the bishop on B6 is doing
a fabulous job at protecting these
weaknesses long term I think White's
going to just uh say the end games why
it should have an advantage exactly Pawn
structure and uh petite little moves B2
B3 Queen C2
reinforcing re protecting maybe on a
good day The Rook could come over the
bishop is always eyeballing this Pawn
one of the worst strategic decisions
black must avoid is by playing E5 takes
D4 because that would be very helpful
the Central Pawn Duo for white as well
as the good Bishop on D2 attacking A5
would be terrible I like how kingside
position is completely symmetrical yes
both players appreciate a well defended
a king again and nothing terrible has
happened to deox position nothing but
for the first time he's not in time
trouble in this tournament he has more
time than his opponent somebody just
knocked him on the head and said you
know you can't do this because your
first four games you've seized the
defensive almost from the get-go and
then you've put yourself in a Hole by
playing on increments for the last 10
moves of the time control and uh
actually players won't let you get away
with them no they won't they they they
they're too good and we do have uh We've
prepared a little graphic we'll show our
audience uh crispr the international
Arbiter who always joins us here in St
Louis is shown as a low graphic
in the middle of the screen
or am I looking right there yes yeah
there you have it 40 moves in 90 minutes
I think that's what he's trying to say
the second time control sudden death
that's all you get you get 30 more
minutes and you always will have a 30
second bonus as we've seen throughout
this tournament a lot of players come to
rely upon that uh 32nd so even though
I'm not saying you know like
um uh Wesley's position is overwhelming
or anything of that nature no no no no I
just really dislike the fact that a
player of Wesley's caliber who just
really enjoys you know nitpicking the
position and finding an awkward
Point here or there he that for him this
is his perfect chess there's nothing
chaotic about it there's no crazy crazy
tactics and he gets to build up the
position from Wesley's point of view
this is his brand of Chess I I wouldn't
want to be in Black's shoes even though
the the engine will probably make the
argument it's fine as always yeah but
there are there are positions that are
easier for one side to play in my view
this is a position for white because I
have a long-term Target what is black
supposed to do is he supposed to be
playing Knight H7 to G5 yay
is he supposed to be playing for D6 D5
is he supposed to be playing exactly
it's not that clear so
answers uh questions and answers to be
to be made Let's jump to the game of
Richie Rapport and Anish Geary because
these two
have been playing some original chess
ever since we saw A7 A6 way back on move
six I want to say and after B4 Knight G4
okay that was a surprise move Queen G5
I think our instinctive reaction was to
play the move Queen G3 to defend the F2
Square after E5 but between move C5 you
Tom is going to say he has a switch and
Zug
E5 C5 okay because again the Knight
cannot move right the the pawn on F2 is
under duress so you have to boot the
queen away Queen went back and now Anish
said okay Knight F5
uh I have a mate threat
pause for just a moment because this is
like kind of weird Bishop sorry Knight
on G4 is also coming in so I have to
take on F5 exactly so this is actually
rather forcing Queen F5 but on the other
hand helps my development right I mean
the knight's been bouncing around the
bishop never moved Knight comes back to
F6 so on a good day black is ready to go
Knight C6 E5 E4 and maybe Rook E5
I hate my king in the center of the
board but white has to Castle thank you
can't wait any longer right I mean you
know you you delayed it as as long as
you possibly could
like
six I'm assuming do you want probably a
to D1
I was thinking that I'm seeing E5 E4
right and I'm seeing that the night is
coming to D4 I'm kind of wanting to get
my pieces out of the way of Knight D4 so
in case of E4 I was wondering can I get
away with this Knight E5 maybe aha
95. good point so that was why you
wanted to play Rook A1 to D1 yeah yes to
meet E4 with Knight to for yes
yes I do like white spawn structure on
the queen side very very much but can
black ever exchange Force exchanges
there yeah you know a timely a6a5 to
break up the team yeah
um
a lot of uh a lot of creative play uh
VAR but did anybody at the end of the
day
have some great claim of Advantage no
actually it's just completely equal but
it's uh it's still some Dynamics I see
in a position but we can we can check
some of the moves now I was analyzing to
see if it looks kind of good for white
but somehow black has good Contra play
in this position so let's see it the
current position he just played the move
Knight C6 and finally Anish Castle it
was move number 20th actually I was
trying to see is when he casts a move 20
White Castle Knight C6
and the best move here is to start with
Rook 81 because black is trying to play
the move E4 here and then jump in on D4
with a knight so that's why Rook 88 is
important and here Rook 8 Rook 81 and
then Rook 88 and now Bishop goes to C4
the idea now is to play Knight G5 to try
to put pressure on F7 so very important
move here for black is H6 to control
that Squish and uh it's uh
it's it's unclear to see what is White
gonna do now here it's hard to improve
the the pieces here so one move actually
even suggested by engine looks
absolutely crazy it's the move G4 here
what yes the idea is to try to play G5
and takes Knight G5
and uh if you play the move
E4
G5
and
again if you take on G5 then actually
white maybe has a little bit of an
advantage here because the F7 Pawn is
weak here and the E4 Pawn could be a
Target as well but for example black can
take on F3
potato she takes F6
and here's block can play rookie 5
immediately or he can actually capture
first on D1 Rook takes D1 and play the
move rookie five here
whoa and the line continues Queen takes
F3 right Rook G5 check
King F1
and now very important to move actually
95.
attacking the queen and the bishop
so forcing the move Queen D5 if white
can trade Queens after Queen d8 will be
a very very big Advantage for white here
so Knight C4 is the only move
and now Queen takes C4
Queen takes H2 now
winning the pawn and Rook d a check King
H7 24 check
and again Jesus Rook G6 is the only move
in this position because if you play the
move G6 that's a very very nice finish
here guys look h a check
gotcha takes Queenie a check King H7
Queen F7 king h8 and queen G7 mate so
you have to play the move Rook G6 uh
after after Queen E4 and a rook G6 kind
of reminds me and this is also pin in
itself so it reminds me of things yeah
yeah and after taking on G7 King G7 uh
looks like uh it's just a roughly equal
position here perhaps it just could be a
draw here after Queen D4 Rook F6 yeah uh
Queen two
lengthy uh variation
there wow I think we're gonna see this I
don't think we're gonna see this line
but it's just it just shows you know how
balanced the position is I'll be amazed
if Anish plays G4 in that position uh
just great stuff and by the way uh Fabi
did go for the Knight takes H3 uh a
Perpetual check that we had envisioned a
long time ago
and I'm reminded of Christian's words
that the preparation of Fabi is so deep
that it could well be that this has been
all uh prepared by him in his opening
Laboratory
Rook takes E5 and white has no choice
but to play the move forward because at
the moment not only is white a pawn down
but his King has actually been shattered
so if you don't have the move F4 You're
simply much much worse so F to F4 which
does after all win an entire Rook
I'm forced to make a Perpetual check
but that's a success for for black
unique Perpetual yeah oh dear wow
remarkable and there you go Rook takes
E5 F4 is coming up and it's going to be
the only move
um we highlighted at the very top of the
show that the Marquee matchup was Ali
Riza farusia and I do believe that after
F2 F4
the players are going to go directly
into that Perpetual check we might just
wait for a quick second let's just see
if we're going to see a handshake
because between Duda because Queen F5
there's no only move Rook takes E5 is
again the only move and queen takes H3
check again the only move King G1 force
and I think we're going to see a
repetition uh very very shortly and a
handshake
wow once again what preparation
I can't imagine how difficult it must be
to play against Bobby I know it's that's
really really frightening uh VAR you did
you you you've seen the type of
preparation that Fabi
has enjoyed over the course of his
career a little bit forgive me if I say
I find this breathtaking this is really
impressive stuff absolutely yeah I've
actually played Fabi uh five or six
games and especially when I was black I
was just really stuck I didn't know what
to play and play the French it didn't go
very well I played the Scandinavian once
also I that didn't go well I played e45
in one game I managed to make a draw
here right with the blocks so but we're
always very difficult to play with the
black pieces especially because his
opening opening preparation is just
phenomenal
well uh definitely today a demonstration
of that now we can jump to the Marquee
match-up game that we were talking about
uh from the top of the show Ali Reza for
rujar defending grandchester Champion
against the new world champion from a
China dingler and when we we left that
we more or less left it at this part and
um this move when you look across the
board and you say well what's the
weakness in Black's Camp it's really not
that much to attack
farouzia decided that he was going to
gnaw upon the pawn on A5 he played the
Moon Knight B3 Bishop B6 Knight D2 and
we immediately understand his ideas to
play Knight to C4 if the bishop is
driven away
much we're happy uh dingler and said no
no I'm not going to give you the pawn
but I will at least give you the two
Bishops
making a little bit of an imbalance in
the position and potentially something
for for white to play for nonetheless 96
this night is looking good you know it's
got It's got outposts that it can jump
to 96 G2 G3 taking control of the F4
Square
I like H5 you're like I do too I do too
King G2 H4 now you don't want to take
that pawn that's kind of like what day I
was at this point yeah that's like ugly
you don't want to take that pawn but on
the other hand you don't want to see
black necessarily uh eyeballing uh the
F4 square that much either so Queenie
two just to take control over the H5
square and D7 pardon me G7 G6 idea of
King G7 and white has the two Bishops
was that a good move though G7 G6
uh sorry it's just logical
something yeah I guess I guess that that
that's true but it does we can block
squares a little bit a lot actually uh
okay G7 G6 fine uh well the purpose of
Knight B3 had been revealed a few moves
earlier at the moment the Knight is no
longer working on B3 let's give it a
better roll Knight D2 and I think we're
up to date with the players 92. nice
looking to come to F3 gift me this phone
or gift me at this point and white has
the two Bishops right and black can take
on G3 right it doesn't mess up black
spawn structure no to exchange the pawns
um and then maybe King G7 and okay okay
and I will fall for uh happily uh fall
into whatever horrible uh Doom Loop
you've prepared for me uh 90 Knight F3
tickling the pawn on E5 I'm thinking
now see if you do go Knight C5 I do have
a a funny way of both defending the E4
Bond as well as maybe maybe
attacking the F7 Pawn
Knight F3
can I sacrifice the pawn on E5 yes yes
okay
now I'll fall for it because I I love
cookies
uh Knight takes E5
now you can go Knight C5
F7 still hangs but it's a little bit
sharp uh you've got Rook H5 ideas
doubling doubling Brooks tickling me
along the the fifth rank
uh
wow uh
okay enterprising stuff and this is the
the kind of game we can sacrifice pods
as well as everybody but let's jump to
uh Bucharest whereas Christian is with
Duda
we are indeed with yanchi stuff uh after
uh his draw against Fabiano caruana
first of all welcome uh to the show if
not for that accident against Richie
Rapport this would have been more or
less a normal tournament 50 now you're
on minus one how how did you assess that
game and how did you try to bounce back
what did you do to bounce back after
that accident uh yeah indeed the game
against report was terrible
um yeah I mean I study in the game miss
this idea King T2 I mean the move itself
and because I thought it's just going to
trade uh everything and and draw but
after King Detroit was suddenly very
tricky yeah visual Band games so um yeah
and I didn't have it at the time also
against that I think I uh I completely
outplayed him but um then I have some
some hallucination because I fought
after 9c1 rubito I can drop the Rook
actually I mean give out the exchange
and then I think the freaking zip but
then here's of course Ruby one I mean
and after I see one uh Ruby tournament
was like no Advantage whatsoever
so um yeah it's a bit a bit annoying of
course
um yeah but what to do yeah I mean I
have to keep going yeah yeah today also
another brilliancy because I
totally totally forgot to check 97 move
which is kind of the mine let's take a
look I think and uh
variations and um yeah at times I was
getting a bit confused because it's uh
like there are lots of foreign
yeah it is the move of course
um yeah what's coming what can I say
yeah
but you took only five and sure he was
blitzing out your moves you looked a
little bit disappointed but this was
quite a funny moment because Jan was
walking around and he saw the position
saw Fabi played Knight C5 and then he
started looking probably calculating
Bishop takes H7
um then understanding that it simply
doesn't work were you surprised about
this move let's see five minutes yes
because F5 was played before another
actually I considered almost only 95
here or black so
um yeah seven I guess doesn't work seven
King H6 and Snyder five I guess yeah
foreign
both of them did you spend any time
calculating it or you were like okay
yeah a little bit Yeah but um I didn't
believe anything I mean with uh one and
B1 it's like uh never really working I
guess for me yeah so
um another line that we're calculating
was Knight G5 did you consider this
uh not really I was
um kind of looking to play very sorry
you know and at this point and um
G5 at all
just to try to pull the brakes uh
make make a draw yeah and here actually
I mean I thought uh
like its new position for me but
actually after this d65 and it takes E5
I had this review that I must have seen
this before this is very perpetual
yeah so after Knight's age 3G takes H3
Queen G5 is one also Queen F5
I think and the point is that after F6
there is Queen A2 tracker which is very
important because otherwise I think I'm
worse and through V6 rook ae1 and it's
um
yeah again like ft 65.324 I think yeah
and pretty much Perpetual yeah so I
guess so I guess I guess it was
um
I mean the result is not so bad of
course but um like the feeling The Taste
after this game is like uh I mean it's
very pathetic gaming I don't want to
forget I guess despite the sure a
disappointing result up to this point
for you for your standards how do you
like the atmosphere here in Bucharest
how do you like the organization talk to
us about that yeah I mean it's nice
tournament for sure but you are always
kind of biased I mean you know you play
well then everything is you know so
great yeah and if you're done then you
know he would
don't feel the same way but still I
can't really complain I mean everything
is top-notch so
um yeah it's nice still four rounds to
recover and get back get some positive
vibes from your results thank you very
much yeah for joining us and we'll see
you in the rest of the games thank you
thank you Christian then thank you uh
dude indeed uh I can't wait to ask Fabi
how much was preparation as we have one
result yes we have one draw between Duda
and Carolina right and uh lots to play
for for in the remaining games and I
just want to bring the attention to the
game of uh Wesley so and again from my
perspective this is like a dream
position for Wesley a lot of players
will say oh it's it's it's even Steven
or something like that I don't believe
that I think that Wesley uh just loves
these types of positions a rich
strategic fight where he has this
long-term advantage of a better Pawn
structure last moves were very nice I
think by Wesley move Bishop E3
intimating that hey look don't pay
attention but I want to trade Bishops
and win the pawn on A5 the bishop was
forced to drop back
lying
excuse me slightly more passive Square
Bishop to C7 Rook to D1 okay making the
move D takes E5 and now after the move
Queen E6 if I'm in Wesley's shoes the
move that has my attention
is C4 okay what I really want to do is I
really want to clamp down on the
position totally with the move d4 D5
and then all of these pawns are on dark
squares what you have to calculate is
d65 yes yes can black play d65 and if he
gets to blow up the center with nothing
untoward happening uh bad that is to say
then he'll be fine
which brings up the other question what
happens if I just capture and let's say
capture and
I try to
festoon my knight on this very powerful
C4 Square where it's kind of looking at
both the E5 and the A5 Pawns
um again I think it's Wesley so's type
of position something he'll enjoy a lot
of good options the clocks oh Wesley's
down to 25 minutes and DF has it 50
minutes twice as much that's surprising
um
and uh jumping uh to you uh VAR as
you've been keeping an eye on the nepo
versus mvl game
yes absolutely looks like nepo is
improving the position at the moment
he's already got a big Advantage here
and we can see the Knight on B7 is very
awkward for mvln the clock situation
Nepal is almost one hour ahead on a
clock mvl has 13 minutes left and a very
very difficult endgame here we can take
a look at the moves now how white can
try to increase his pressure in this
position here so we left off around here
after Bishop D6 Knight C5 and he played
the move Bishop B5
and Knight B7 was played here so he did
not he did not take on B5 and we all
decided to play the move Knight B7 but
now after Bishop 83 if we just look at
it the Knight is really passive here and
the bishop on a tree is doing a great
job taking away the squares the Knight
can go to on C5 or D6 here so Rook C7
played
and now F3 I like this move it's a
really nice move restricting the squares
for the Knight and also it will allow
you to bring the King on F2 bring it
closer to the center and Rook a seat
again black is doubling up the Rooks
here but there is no target here just
trying to bring the Rook into the game
and rookie Rook D2 played doubling up
the Rooks another very logical move here
eight balls Rook 81 so white has
improved all his Pieces perhaps you can
also play the wolf King F2 next in the
meantime it's not so clear to see what
is white uh what is black going to do
here and he doesn't have that much time
here he's got 13 minutes we still have a
13 more 13 more moves to go here to make
the time control very very difficult
position for mvl I mean G5 is one of the
best options but it's it's very hard to
even understand what is the purpose of
this move let's take a look at more
concrete moves here let's say if he
plays the move Knight D5 here try to
liquidate some pieces here here actually
why I can just simply play the move King
F2 right which that was the idea to play
the move F2 so you always have this
option to bring your king closer to the
center if Knight takes E3 King takes E3
now
again the Knight on B7 is really badly
placed here and uh if you if you take on
B5
simply Pawn takes B5 and now we have the
option of going Rook D7 here as well
white has a very big advantage in this
line if we try to keep the
D file closed with the move uh Bishop D5
then y can try to prepare the move C4
first start with the move Rook D4
let's let's say black is just just for
example if he's not doing anything King
h8
and we can try to even expand on this
side of the board here too since black
has no ideas you can even play the move
H4 you can G8 even H5 just gets a more
space advantage and eventually white
will be able to play the move C4 to
remove the bishop here for example you
can even go Rook C1 and then play C4 or
perhaps at the right time maybe King D3
as well and to play the move C4 very
nice Advantage for white here two
Bishops uh majority on the queen side
here I think Nepal has excellent chances
to win this game guys yeah it sure feels
the same way to me when I think of the
Lapin as an opening I always think of
white trying to play for Queen side
majority but that's like a dream
position white has everything he has a
queen side majority
complete control of the open file and
this Knight on B7 simply makes a woeful
impression the Knight on B7 is in a very
passive Square the bishop on A3
patrolling f8 stopping King f-187 I just
start adding up all of the advantages
and I say
exactly at this moment who's ever in the
2800 Club I would rate that player as a
favorite to win absolutely with the
white pieces like this is a type of
position that a Magnus Carlson you know
Karu Nakamura Wesley so once they get
their grip on you you're not getting out
of it and we just saw the move King H7 a
kind of indication that
[Music]
um
yeah waiting uh and a light I love that
incremental Advance King F2 and so forth
turning our attention to Wesley soap
Wesley is on the outside looking in he
has a plus one score very very nice uh
hoping that maybe you could get plus two
to today and join uh Fabi in the lead
you know here I am sitting there
extolling the virtues you know of a
great Pawn structure for Wesley and play
the move C4 and play D5 or take on E5
and play Knight to D2 stick your knight
on this beautiful uh outpost on C4
B3 B4 inviting black to uh trade off his
his Pawn on A5 I find this move
confounding uh help me out right this
idea is still a pronapsody file and put
pressure on the C6 spawn okay let's do
it right right
yep well it takes back right and here D5
is looking also good not for black oh
pardon me yes oh okay sorry uh you want
to play the Black side okay so you you
think Wesley's idea was to open up the C
file that that maybe he underestimated
Black's intention of uh playing move d65
okay so now I'm going to be playing
Wesley's uh side okay first of all I'm
still confounded by the move B4 but
let's say that the idea was that I I
want to focus my attention on uh the C6
Pawn right so away I go like
gift me the bond uh let's say I just
defend with the Knight E7 Knight to E7
Fair
and can I munch
the pawn on E5 in this so in this
fashion I'm thinking if you take twice
on E5 I'll have Bishop D4 and maybe that
will be a little bit awkward for you
okay
um
there's so many pawns to take which one
yeah
well this one no no
yeah no this one's no no it takes C4
let's take a look okay so I gotta take
take back take take back and Knight D5
okay I see what you're up to
okay but I'm a pawn grubber Oh no you're
not trying to take the bond you're
trying to Fork three I was about to play
Bishop C5 and then suddenly Knight C3 is
a game changer okay so that's the so you
want to play rough
you want to play rough Knight to D4 give
me
the pawn on C6 I'm trying to convince
you to move your queen so I can play
Queen takes E5 okay
are we just gonna be making the
tradition yeah like like
I feel like the cleaning uh the the
cleaner just came in and just swept the
whole board before yeah good job
that's it that's that's a good move you
just traded everything off and uh a
handshake indeed is uh what's in store
here
all right as we get prepared for break
please once again we would like to
invite you to join the discussion your
social media questions have been very
very well received over the first four
days of broadcast we've enjoyed your
questions so uh get ready as we come
back uh for from broadcast and as we
leave you we have yet another special
from Bucharest as Christian was catching
up with more chess fans and asking them
about the competition have a look
thank you
we are here at the playing venue with
Berta who is a chess fan and came here
Berta welcome to the show tell us a bit
about your chess experience
so last year was very nice very
attention when you see the players there
playing all the time and we see you in
the same time many games is very
interesting also but tension sometimes
you keep with one of the players and not
yours will be the winner he's very nice
in the well very well organized when did
you start playing chess and what is your
average level let's see my level is 900
and some on chess.com but I'm playing
every day I'm trying to get a better
better performance but I don't know how
it be in the future I'm also registrated
to a chess club
but I'm trying what attracts you to
chess is it the social aspect going to
the club and playing with other people
what is it yeah what you mentioned it's
been interesting to play with colleagues
to try to catch some technique to have a
plus plus value
this is my
your interesting chess and tell us a bit
about this particular tournament who is
your favorite player
in reality my favorite
but from here is Nepal Nepal yeah well
that was a heartbreak a couple of weeks
ago uh because he lost against I was
almost cry after the game this is it God
willing yes also well Berta it's a
pleasure to see you here it's a pleasure
to see the environment here
um with these amazing players at the
Superbad chess classic thank you very
much for taking the time thank you
[Music]
thank you
meet me
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedies romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org the beauty in Forest Park
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the superbet tournament and we have our
results so far right
right today and it'll draw between dudai
and caruana a very very well played
correct game I might add uh the four
games that do remain are all quite
exciting indeed I want to jump quickly
to the game of Ali Reza and dingler in
because again this was one of these
Marquee games as we came into today's uh
round saying keep an eye on this one and
check this out
I want to say a very intuitive sacrifice
uh here by Ali Reza he decided to give
up his E4 Pawn for
well is it a serious attack Knight F3
exchange on a G3 followed by Knight
takes E4 okay 95. now please take my
knight develop my bishop and put
yourself in the very very nasty pin no
thank you said ding Loren
I'd rather play Knight back to D6 Bishop
A2 preserving the attacking Bishop your
full Pawn down if you will Rook E8 to
defend the spawn on E5 and there's
an intuition is an attacking intuition
that players have
that you just sometimes you get
mystified by and you say where did you
come up with this concept
that attack could be had Bobby Fischer
had it Gary Kasparov had it Michael Tall
had it in Spades and this is a type of
position you just say I don't get you
know I'm upon up and then you say okay
your turn I'm going to play Rook F1
two immediate threats no immediate
threats but if it was my turn like I'm
going to make a bad move for you Bishop
D2 here and you might just simply be
lost yes like Rook takes F6 Queen takes
F6 Rook F1 and oopsie Daisy this bishop
on A2 Knight takes F7 uh harmonic
convergence suddenly lands on F7 and
you're simply gone so uh after for
example rookie 8 the current position if
I play Rook F1 or Bishop D2 I'm not even
sure which is the best approach I just
say I'm slowly slowly I'm about to play
Bishop D2 and Rook F6 do something say
King G7 excellent move King G7 and
Bishop T2
so Rook F6 is a threat you start feeling
the threat now that Kingston on G8 yes
because now let's say if it was white to
play and play Rook F6 I take back Rook
F1 you're not released the king is
better placed on a G8
E4 here E5 E4
fair question let's just check if it's
losing or not after a cup six let's have
a look-see rook takes F6 Queen takes
Rook F1 Queen E5 Queen E5 pause
uh because Knight takes F7 is a Tempo
but I'm also find myself attracted to
Bishop F4 which is another Tempo I also
had Knight F5 I just noticed instead of
Queen E5 I don't know if that's better
but what what Knight F5 Knight F5 you
sure did
Knight F5 and you've got ideas of e3
which Cuts me off
I can capture on F7 but I'm kind of
afraid of the E3
great stuff I'm telling of our uh when a
Christian said he highlighted this game
at the start of the show and he said
dingler in and Ali Reza going to play a
marquee matchup he had this kind of a
fight in mind
it has Ali Reza intuited that he has
enough for the sacrifice Pawn
I think he had a really nice advantage
and I will show you if we go back a few
more moves I think the current position
is actually quite unclear and I think
the last move rookie 8 might be a slight
inaccuracy by dingler in okay and he
could have played the move E4 for
example but let me show you the the
critical part here so after the move
Knight C5 here this is a really nice
Advantage here for white in this
position so he played the move Knight F3
another option would have been to play
the move G4 okay the idea is you don't
want to allow any Contra player the next
move you play the move Knight F3 as well
I really like this setup for example one
of the only moves here is to play Knight
H7 now and then you play Knight F3
opening up the diagonal for the bishop
and now you're pressing pressuring the
pawn only five so King G7
and now you can play with the move
before even here
and uh now the Knight needs to uh go
away you don't really want to take on
before because after CB there will be
also potential of uh the move Bishop B2
for example take
Pawn takes
Knight E6 to try to get to F4 but in
this case after Bishop takes E6 26 we
play the move A5 and it's pretty clear
that white has a very nice Advantage
here right so this was one option here
Knight F3 move he played G4 would have
given nice Advantage Knight F3 is fine
as well here so the game continued uh
htx G3 ft xg3 and now played the move
Knight ce4 and here he played a move uh
Knight G5 here this is this is a this is
a mistake actually he should have played
the move here Bishop A2 first
very very deep move here and now let's
say if you play King G7
right now you see
with the idea to play G5 remove the
knight from here and now E4 and Knight
is hanging and if you move the Knight
anywhere you lose the E5 Pawn here so
this is actually a very big Advantage
here for White Knight F2 is Knight F2 or
Knight D6 are the best options but after
Knight takes E5 here
white has a really really strong
uh well actually sorry here Knight F2
Queen takes C5 here in this case and
queen takes E5 Knight E5 and there's a
pressure on F7 there's a nice initiative
here for white here
so Advantage here but in in the game we
have uh if we go back to the game after
FG he played uh Knight G5
and logical move but perhaps he missed
this move Knight D6 or underestimated
this idea because after Knight takes G5
Bishop G5 white has a really nice
position here Rook F1 is coming a lot of
pressure here F7 is really weak but
after Knight D6 there is a Tempo here on
the bishop and you have to move the
bishop back here and here ding had a
strong move E4 really yes and now you
want to put the pawn on E3 actually to
Simply shut down this bishop and also
you cannot move the bishop to connect
your Rooks here so this actually a big
Advantage here uh for uh for black
Bishop F4 for example sure and now
strong move Knight H5 attacking the
bishop and if you take on D6 there is
Queen takes G5 now
and uh Queen G4 for example and here you
can even play the move King G7 so this
would have been a nice Edge
for black but instead he played the move
rookie 8. and I think this is the
current position here and white has only
one move in this position he needs to
find a move Bishop F4 here really
absolutely necessary move here otherwise
he will be in big trouble here so that's
why I'll Reza is thinking here he's
trying to figure out what to do but the
move Bishop F4 is necessary here you
cannot take on F4 because the queen is
hanging on his own you will lose an
exchange and it's a very sharp line
after this bishop F4 Knight H5
and here you can play uh you have a few
options you can play the move Rook 81
which is a very logical move bring the
last piece into the game and now you
have some potential ideas Rook D6 Knight
F7 or Bishop F7 Knight takes F4 you play
G takes F4
again now pressure a lot of pressure we
see on F7 and
black needs to play this move King G7 to
move away from the diagonal of the
bishop here and here Queen takes if I
can take with a pawn because G5 Knight
is hanging so you'll have to play the
move Queen E5 check and with the King on
G7 now you have this excellent move
Queen F6 because you don't really want
to capture only five because that will
allow F takes E5 and Rook will go to the
seventh rank but if you play Queen F6
the Knight is very stable on D6
blockading the rook and also defending
the crucial F7 pawn and black is black
is okay here it's just equal position
thank you for our talk about Cowboys wow
uh positions are blowing up all over the
place uh napo's Advantage may have
slipped considerably whereas Richard
Rapport may have been getting a serious
Advantage but while all of these actions
are going on we have asked and you have
delivered a social media questions and
we've got an enormous amount of tweets
and we welcome them so let's just go
with the queen survival
the question is what do you think of
blindfold chess should it be
incorporated into competitions like this
I admire the people greatly who play
blindfold chess and our child out to
then find gold and Larry Christensen
amongst American players who play
blindfold chess really really very well
I never thought
I was any particularly good I can do
like maybe three games uh Maurice can do
10 games uh I just find it you know it
it it it's really really uh amazing for
audiences who don't know that you you
know blindfold it's a great exhibition
right but uh chess is already tough when
you can see the board I don't know about
you
are you a blindfold player could you
play five games for example simultaneous
I've never tried more than three well
Nevermore three of us
yes but I always recommend it to my
students to play a blind because it
helps you with uh calculating in your
head in advance like 10 moves or so
because when you're calculating that far
you can't really see the position
clearly right and plain blindfold chess
kind of trains you to be able to picture
the position always clearly in your head
and that is what you do you do picture
the whole board and VAR jump in uh do
you recommend blindfold for your
students and have of are you
particularly good yourself I actually
played a lot of blindfold chairs when I
was a kid when I was traveling to some
tournament with my friends so we played
a lot of blindfold with Lavon aronia and
Gabrielle sargassian we played a lot of
blindfold just growing up uh the Maxima
I've played was about five boards I
think I once did a simul but it was very
difficult I was extremely tired and it
was a lot of stress doing the blindfold
simul here I think I I recommend to my
students to play you know try to develop
that vision of the board and the way I
do it I just try to recollect the
position when I play in the game I
always try to remember the it's like I
have the board I can see it in my in my
head and follow it through like that
definitely I can play one or maybe two
games on a good level but more than that
it gets very difficult sometimes you
lose the the side of the positions
exactly exactly but to answer the
question they also asked should it be
incorporated in tournaments like this
for the players I think it would be fun
to watch them make terrible blunders
yeah they'll struggle a bit but it
depends if they do uh some very serious
training like I I've been at numerous
dinners for example uh with Fabi where
I'll just ask him you know like what
happened today and they go and I go well
what happens if you go like this
and so and so on so they have very good
sight of the board uh one more tweet and
we'll jump back into the games uh as uh
Anish Gary seems to be suffering here's
a question
how do the commentators feel about this
new era in chess where Magnus is sitting
out more and the playing field is a lot
more equivalent and exciting interesting
question
Nasi jump in with you're missing
Magnus yes of course I am yes
King Kong is not in town right but I
wouldn't say he's really sitting out
that many tournaments he plays every
rapid tournament I think and we're gonna
see him play very soon and wrap it on
Blitz right and uh
it is interesting to see tournaments
without him because I feel like every
tournament that he played he won pretty
much so I do miss him but it's also
interesting to see how other players
play without him right these emergence
of for example dingleren and nepo and so
forth uh
for for me I mean it's like I do see a
lot of Magnus don't get me wrong I mean
he's online and he's playing as you say
in a lot of rapid and Blitz and it seems
to me he's keeping a pretty busy
schedule but yes if you asked me I would
love to see him in the grand chess tour
yes I would love to have seen him in the
world championship match and yes I'd
love to see him in the sinkfield cup I
mean I just think he is a generational
player a great world champion I mean
nothing else to be said and yeah I miss
him uh jump in VAR absolutely yeah it's
it's always great to see Magnus play and
uh we're gonna see him in our next
tournament in Warsaw rapid and Blitz
tournament after that he's also going to
play in a super United wrapping them
Blitz in Zagreb Croatia it clearly shows
that he prefers his rapid and Blitz
formats nowadays and uh I think I expect
to see him do really well in this both
tournaments he usually wins them or
finishes at the very very top and I also
agree with that Magnus the competition
is more even now and gives an
opportunity to the other players to
think why can't they win this tournament
for example why not indeed let's jump
back into the games as a Richie Rapport
have a point behind Fabi saying hey look
what you're doing a niche your pieces
are going backwards my pieces are going
forwards we left it around these parts
and we expected castles Knight C6 this
one was a little bit of a surprise for
us uh much more natural would appear to
be the move Rook on A1 to D1 followed by
Bishop to G Bishop to C4 and even there
was a possibility of G2 G4 for white
which was Far pointed out alien movie
yeah an alien move indeed and then after
Rook D1 I was a little bit uh perplexed
by this one Knight E1 I think Anish well
first of all he wasn't drawn to the move
G4 that is very very clear and
from his perspective he's seeing the
move E5 E4 and he's seeing Knight to D4
and I think he's getting himself a
little frustrated that he doesn't have
an active plan himself so he kind of got
out of the way if you will of this
coming initiative and well Richard said
well thank you very much you go
backwards I'll go forwards Knight D4 E4
uh grabbing space grabbing squares along
the way and always when I think about
these positions I come back to what you
had said earlier uh Nasi and that is
should black play the move A5
break up the team a little bit over
there like I want to play Knight before
I really do I really really want to play
Knight D4 but maybe I can do it on my
terms and try to get you to play B4 so
that when B4 B5 pardon me so that when I
get to play Knight D4 my favorite yeah
exactly my favorite living condition uh
Richard wasn't interested in tossing in
the move A5 he went for Knight D4 right
away and we'll catch up with the players
Queen G3
uh HD3 Richard I guess very reluctantly
agreed to the trading of the Queens he's
played Knight G I like this 9g form I
love this move Knight G4 prepping Knight
E5 getting out of the way of the F5 Pawn
trying to use the majority and finally
and much more directly maybe just ready
to play E4 E3 right up the gut and how
big I mean it visually it looks good for
Richie how big of an advantage is it
really VAR it's a very very big
Advantage here plus one here for uh
Richie here and one thing I noticed yes
sir Anish played so many moves with the
queen in this game you know and it
started out with the move Queen G5 and
the move that we were not sure about
then since then I I counted he played
like at least I think about eight moves
with a queen in this game so far out of
the 30 played or so yeah out of the yeah
29 moves in the current position by just
looking at it you can tell that he all
his pieces are on the background here
which literally every piece he has Rooks
the Knight it's extremely passive
position here and the re-chatting has
good chances here in this game he's a
little bit behind on the clock though 29
minutes against 13 but the best move
here to continue I think is to start out
with the move G5 okay then you give
yourself the chance to play uh King G7
F5 and try to expand on that King side
here a very passive defense uh for for
white here he can play perhaps a move
like Rook a B1
and trying to at some point prepare a 4
B5 and here you can play King G7 you can
play slow and try to build up but also
you can play more concrete with the move
E3 here
and now the threat is E2 it's extremely
strong threat so you're forced to
capture and now Knight takes a tree
Knights are very active here putting a
lot of pressure here and after a rook
let's say Rook D3 which is the best move
you can play the move even G4 here
completely fixing the structure here
very difficult to find moves here the
Knight only one has no squares it's you
know you were trying to maybe go to
Knight to F3 now but after the move G4
you can't even do that so very big
Advantage if you reach your report here
I think he has good chances here nasty
crap it just feels like uh the Knight on
E1 and uh kind of an advanced Fisher
random by why putting all of his pieces
on the first rank keto and doesn't it
doesn't feel good
I like Black's position I also say it
might be a little bit easy for black
Black's advantage to slip away if black
doesn't play accurately precisely yeah
because if you play for example E3 right
away
which is not a natural looking move for
me I like I love playing with the
majority and uh it's my trump is black
uh the king side majority so I find
moves F5 and G5 as the most natural
moves in the position I might slightly
prefer G5 because oftentimes I like
playing the king to G7 somehow it just
feels like in the game of dingler end
the king's a little bit more yeah you
improve a little bit so F5 G5 King G7
but then before I really start reaching
for them I start thinking about the E3
E4 E3 and maybe that's going to bring me
Glory right away in fact Richie played a
little bit well a lot more sedate he
played the move Rook to D5 Bishop to C4
Rook to D1 and potential and he's just
hoping for a repetition he would be very
happy to get out of uh here and again
tomorrow is a free day and Richie's
place so far does Belize the idea that
he's willing to accede to a repetition I
don't think that that's what's going to
happen VAR I see you've got the dingler
ring game behind you let's jump into it
what's happening in dingler ends game
well uh firusha didn't play that more
Bishop F4 guys the move that we were
analyzing sure and now I I think he is
in serious trouble here so let's take a
look so the move that he had to play in
this position was the move Bishop F4
which would have lead to a dynamic but
equal position at the end he will
recapture the pawn only five but instead
he played the move H4 kind of a very
calm move like it's not like he's down
upon he's just strengthening the
position here and now uh Rook 88 is uh
there are two moves here you can play
Rook 88 or King G7 so I think just
played move King G7 it's a very logical
move we saw this move actually played in
a lot of the variations you really want
to step away from this diagonal where
the bishop is just putting pressure and
also sometimes Queen C2 Queen G6 ideas
can happen so it's a really good
preventing move here so King G7 is split
and I think now alireza is thinking
trying to figure out what to do I don't
see how he can continue here so there
there are two options here for him he
can play the move for example Rook F1 to
try to put some pressure on the f file
but now black can continue with the move
Queen D7 which is the best move
and
Queen the idea of this move is now
you're threatening to play Queen C6
check so for example if Queen F3 Queen
C6 and you will be able to exchange
coins and after that you have a extra
pawn and a comfortable Advantage here so
it's it's hard to see where is the
compensation here at some point this
move E4 E3 will be played as well Knight
F4 Knight F5 is another possibility uh
so after look F1 Queen D7 black is much
better if he goes back to this original
idea of Bishop F4 now there are some
options here for blackish and for
example you actually can play either
Knight D E4 or Knight F E4 blockading
the e-file here they're both about the
same as strength this move so let's
start out with the move Knight D E4
now the idea is if you capture only four
that will allow me to move it takes F4
and now black is simply winning because
of the pin on the e-file so very nice
idea uh Knight D or fe4 here and now you
have to come back and play a move like
Bishop C1 which is not that great here
so difficult position here for alireza
and his has 11 minutes on a clock width
14 moves to go dink has 23 minutes I see
a
good chances here for the world champion
to perhaps to score his first victory in
this tournament something he desperately
needs I like to turn our attention to
the game between Jan and MBL for just a
moment I'm going to go back earlier
because this for me was very very
confusing when we left the position we
left it just about after the move King
H7 king of two G5 now exactly here I
look at this position
and I say what are my trumps is white
what are your trumps is black for me the
fact that I have the double Rooks on the
D file this is an excellent Bishop
that's patrolling this diagonal and this
is a terrible night on B7 in my mind
wides majority on the queen side that's
my trump so I really desperately I want
to play the move C4 I want to play B3
which kind of fixes the queen side so
that I can play Bishop B2 once I
eliminate this Knight on F6 I get to
play Rook D7 it's like then sign the
score sheets so C4 B3 would have been on
my gen and I find this move H4 very
confounding because when I play the move
H4 I'm playing on the king side where
black has the majority so I feel I'm
playing in my opponent's kitchen and I
shouldn't be over there I should be
where I have an advantage after H4 King
G6 takes takes I've I'm saying well
haven't I helped Black's position the
the Rooks on the half open C file aren't
very good whereas I've opened up the H
file and maybe I'm just simply helping
my opponent and it feels to me that
after quite a sequence of moves we've
reached the position where a lot if not
all in fact of the advantages just
simply disappear I mean I can see that
from mvl's point of view the Knight on
B7 suddenly well in the very near future
has a square whereas the Rooks have
really good squares uh The Rook coming
doubling on the open H file well I mean
it's not that difficult to see Rook H2
and Rook H3 mate where did I mean if
that's not a self
uh you know created a problem I don't
know what is so I think nepo's Advantage
has disappeared whereas uh take a look
if you don't mind about the Wesley so uh
dioc position
again I've been extol in Wesley's
strategic play and it feels to me like
despite the material balance
Wesley Wesley all the way absolutely
Wesley has a very nice advantage and
this is a very difficult defense for the
Acura Knight on F5 is excellent the pawn
on D6 is going to be weak the whole time
and even some night end games with the
Bishops even if we take the Rooks off
the boat for example which is going to
be very hard for black to do white will
keep that one Rook to pressure on D6
it'll be very difficult to defend this
position here so I see some good
opportunities for Wesley to try to win
this game and get to that plus two score
and catch Fabiano here let's take a look
what is the best way that can try to
defend this end game right so the first
thing he needs to do I think was pretty
clear he needs to put this bishop on a
f8 okay so you have the freedom to move
the Rook because otherwise your rookies
always have to defend this and now I
think Wesley has two options uh he can
play rookie A1 or Rook se1 so he needs
to try to get a rook on one of the open
files so Rook A1 for example now after
this movie have Rook A6 ideas to putting
pressure on the six also you can play
Rook A7 here right it would be very nice
for black to somehow exchange this
Knight on F5 or somehow play the move G6
but it's not going to be easy to do that
so if you play the move Knight F6 here
to try to attack the pawn before now
Knight will jump in uh to D2 here
protecting E4 and now you're preparing
this move F3 with the idea of Knight C4
to Target this really weak Pawn on D6 so
you need to try to play actively perhaps
the move Knight F4 could be played here
but immediately we see problems here
Rook A6 now targeting the D6 spawn you
have to play Rook d8 now
and even in this line with Bishop takes
F4 you have you have a nice Advantage
here as well uh the one thing it's
cleared with the move Knight F4 you are
threatening to play this smooth G6 so
white needs to do something here in this
position against that so uh if you take
immediately on F4 Pawn takes you can
play the move
F3
the idea is to protect E4 so you're
ready to play the move Knight C4 here
but now black has G6
Knight to D4 now again we have an
excellent Square for the Knight to go to
on C6 right still a big Advantage for
white it's like plus one but again this
is the very best way to play for black
and with all these accurate moves you're
still in a difficult position here but
if you don't find this moves you could
simply drop the D6 spawn and then after
I lose the game
thank you uh for that all right I really
feel like uh poor diac uh his whole
first four rounds in fact the first half
of the tournament has been a little bit
nightmarish for him because
you know the chat should be fine and all
he's been doing is you know like
fighting for survival and it looks like
he's uh doing the same thing uh once
again uh by the way in the game between
Richie and Anish Gary no repetition in
fact G7 G5 one of the computer's top
choices uh not surprisingly was played
by Richie but he has four minutes to
make 11 moves
Richie that's a problem that's a problem
that time management makes it full of
all of us but G7 G5 yes great move ready
for King G7 F5 and just gradual
Improvement it's an end game so it's not
as difficult to make 11 moves with 4
minutes especially when you have an
initiative sorry correct but if the
position still requires precise moves
then that's when time travel is going to
be a problem exactly but I liked also
like it's very easy to get confounded by
the fact that this Knight on E1 really
doesn't have a future at the moment so
imagine you were white and you thought
okay well what's the problem I'm just
going to use my king side majority for
Queen's pardon me I'm just going to use
my queen side majority for a moment I'm
going to call A4 B5 and everything like
this and I think VAR pointed out a very
Salient feature in the position which is
that after E3 takes Knight takes Rook DD
D2 you're you may be thinking oh you
know what's what's so bad about my
position and you start looking at the
position after G fourth which is a
second and go where's my active play you
know pause on G2 and G3 just just make a
bad impression so much uglier after G4
don't they yeah and the Knight on E1
looks really really passive and now
after you've played a move like B5 even
the bishop is starting to complain and
saying well I don't have a as much range
as I did a moment ago the pawns are not
threatening in and of themselves but I
just like I just think that White's
pieces are simply passive and for a
player like Anish who prides himself on
his
classical understanding of Chess and he
likes playing aggressive chess when he
can he's not going to be happy about the
position
that's shown up on the board for Richie
wow a victory today it's hyper first
free day yeah I mean the heart skips a
beat it's such a possibility
and
we we thank you for your social media
joining the conversations and let's
let's take a tweet
this one is from Isaiah 17 76. yes sir
how can that in your own losses improve
your game slash skill well don't Focus
too much on your losses uh your wins are
help you improve your game as well but
it's absolutely true that studying your
losses
will inspire you to get a deeper
understanding the position why did I
lose the game why did I overlook my
opponent's play and if you
can take away something positive from a
loss by by giving yourself what you hope
will be additional knowledge then yeah
you can kind of feel like that loss was
fruitful of sorts but in truth I mean uh
study your wins as well I mean
what you do what you do well what
brought you success
um study your games
you learned a lot from your losses for
sure yes but you also learned a lot from
your wins right yes because if if you
win that means your opponent made some
mistakes so from every game you can
learn something
someone made some inaccuracies or
mistakes exactly and I think that's like
you said The only positive about losing
a game is that you're going to analyze
and learn
where you need to improve what mistakes
you made and hopefully not repeat them
again exactly for me the worst loss the
worst losses it's absolutely I despise
myself when this happens is when I lose
because of a completely egregious
blunder I learn nothing from the game
and you know it's gonna happen again
yeah I hate it uh jump in coach
I I can't remember you ever losing a
game but uh jump in tell us about wins
and losses and learning from them no
I've lost many many games yes sir and uh
game analysis has been always a big part
of my game I've saved and analyzed all
my games for the past 25 years I keep a
very a nice archives of all the games
after each Tournament game I analyze it
and you use you improve a lot by doing
that finding out your mistakes if you if
you play the bad game and try to fix
that to make sure it doesn't happen in
in the next game also if your opponent
makes a mistake you recognize that in
this certain positions this kind of move
could lead to a difficult position so I
would and I also spend a lot of time
analyzing my students games and that's
the big part when they come back from
tournaments we go over the games try to
pay attention to the losses in
particular where there were some
mistakes sorry I have to jump in here
VAR and interrupt you for just a moment
because I'm looking at what Jana's doing
and I Jana we're gonna put Jan on
suicide watch what the heck was this
last move uh by Yan uh here I already
questioned much of his play why am I
helping my opponent open up the king
side with the move h4h to hg5 why am I
not keeping the H file closed and after
this move Bishop A3 Knight to E5 Bishop
B2
this move must have just surprised uh
Eon rook h8 and I can't understand he
was probably thinking in his Mind's Eye
that you can't allow Bishop takes E5
like Bishop B takes E5 I'll double your
pawns and
NBL said what's the problem Bishop takes
E5 is not a problem almost 10 moves
black improved the position
significantly like yeah with each turn
right even worse and worse exactly from
Black's perspective the double pawns
there's nothing to fear this Pawn on E6
is doing a great job keeping the night
out furthermore Rook D6 is not a check
so thank you for the pawn last times one
night on B7 is not bad well it ain't
gonna last on B7 that much longer
because I gotta tell you that is one of
the sweetest looking outposts the Knight
on C5 never mind upon on B E3 which I'm
always constantly thinking about but E5
E4 Rook H3 check
I wouldn't be surprised if this position
simply is much better it's black just
women the black
very easily rookie Rook H3 is a a
winning threat
MBL was in time trouble but now he only
has two moves to make
and for which the time control well this
just feels such a great position exactly
by the way you're talking about the
night on B7 after a move like Rook H2
check your knight might go to this G2
Square where it'll disappear for the
rest of the game like what's it doing on
G2 uh versus a fabulous Knight on C5 VAR
where we're seeing nepo implode in these
last two games uh before the free day
tomorrow absolutely yeah sir I can't
even explain the decisions he's making
so far in this game I mean in the past
10 moves block just completely improved
his pieces and is opening up this H file
it was completely unnecessary he should
have never even played H for the first
place because you know as you mentioned
clearly he allowed opponent to gain
Contra play right and and this last few
moves as well now he's actually
completely lost it's like plus four for
mvl here 95. yeah I've just played uh
yeah yeah it's uh perhaps 95 wasn't even
the best move Rook H2 was the best to
play in this position Rook H2 check
Knight G2 and then Knight comes to C5
and and suddenly all of the pieces for
black are very active now B3 Pawn is
under attack there are so many threats
in this position if you take only five
just try to reduce the pressure by
eliminating one of the pieces now Pawn
takes back now the question is how are
you going to protect your Pawn on B3
right and if you try to defend with
something like Rook B2 then E4 disaster
opening up the position of the king and
uh it's it's very clear this position is
going to collapse
and by the way this is a reflection
remarkably enough of uh well we're not
going to call it an adoption
but I we do want to say that mvl rather
owns uh their uh classical chess rivalry
I'm sure in Rapid chess and Blitz chess
uh the different results but one win
only for nepo versus the many losses
that definitely affects you
psychologically when you play an
opponent who has a very good score
against you absolutely one more thing
guys I wanted to mention once again if
we look at the clock Yan still has 30
minutes to go and the question comes
could you maybe spend a little bit of
time right because he still has this 30
minutes but now completely ruin this
position and just spend a little bit of
time at least to shut down when things
are going wrong at least you need to
shut down the game and now I think
there's a good chance he's going to lose
this game and from essentially pretty
much a winning position he had about 15
15 10 15 moves ago a remarkable
remarkable turnaround the double Rooks
on the D file are now like vacuous empty
space whereas the double Rooks on the H
file very very menacing everything about
Black's position is harmonized and
White's position is a complete uh fail
let's go jump uh once again Wesley so
enjoying his position he's just played
the move Knight on F3 to D2 ready to
play F2 F3 Knight C4 uh Wesley in
control of this one but Anish Gary and
Richie report whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
we left it we just saw the move
King G7 G5 and King G7 makes sense A4
at least three or four of this was my
analysis because I was saying that after
F5 I didn't believe in this expansion B5
a b
Bishop takes B5 well that wasn't the
follow-up we wanted when you played
sorry maybe if I was a little bit slow
and he should have played E3 right away
okay F7 F5 uh I can't be too critical uh
maybe E3 what was a better choice and G4
like the line we're looking at exactly
but b5ab Bishop takes B5 it again I'm a
structure guy and when I see a white
inflicting this damage to his own
structure I say congratulations well
played you show great a great knowledge
Knight takes B5 a takes B5
ah because we're not
we're not dominating the night as we
previously would have been when the pawn
was on F7 and we could have played G4
95 I still like Richie's position a lot
but did he spoil something by not
jumping in there with that E3 move R
absolutely now an evaluation is actually
just equal at the moment and yeah Richie
he spoiled it a lot F5 F5 was the
critical uh error actually he's only
he's got a minute on a clock with uh
still uh six moves to go and I think
that was a big factor in his decision to
play a five he had to play the move E3
in that position I will show you some uh
key lines I think to to realize why uh
in this position he didn't have to play
the move F5 F5 this B5 is actually a
very serious idea to gain a contra play
that's why he needed to play the move E3
to now threaten the movie two after
capture Knight takes E3 and I think we
had a similar variation the variation
that we looked at it after Rook D3 G4
and now white cannot really move
anything here so this is a very pleasant
position maybe you can play King F2 but
even after Knight takes F1 King takes F1
this Knight is still stuck only one
cannot go anywhere here Knight C2 you
cannot go I have Rook F5 checks so very
very difficult position in fact uh I'm
actually threatening to give a mate just
an example you play this really bad move
check
King G1
92 and now we see the idea behind the
smooth G4 because you can check by the
opponent here so this E3 was very strong
uh to play Move 31 here but he's he's
got about two minutes on the clock so he
played the move B5
a B I think it's possible he uh maybe
missed Bishop B5 but even after a takes
B5
you know white is very slightly better
after Knight E5 so it's still playable
like this but the problem after Bishop
B5 you it's a Tempo you Tempo on a rook
and you can in every line you try to
move the Rook up let's say you play
rookie five here you're gonna run into
this move Knight C2 which is crucial
because now you're attacking the Knight
on D4 and you cannot capture because the
eighth Rook is hanging so you have to
play in let's say 96 here right and now
Rook can take on the eighth Knight takes
the eight now suddenly the Knight was
only one and now it's on D4 the
centralized position putting pressure on
F5 and if you take here just Bishop D7
and white has a very good Contra player
here but we have couple of moves here
guys let's catch up right to see what
happened here it was uh Bishop takes B5
Knight takes B5 ab5 and Knight E5 it's
been played bar yeah Knight C2 played by
Anish trying to bring the Knight into
the game very logical move Knight free
and
c66 and here again rich is paying on 30
second increment so he doesn't have time
to get into the position here so perhaps
he could have played the move Rook D5
here first uh the idea is to put
pressure and if you take on B7 we have
to move Rook B8 here not not an easy
move to find so he didn't play that he
played B Tech C6 Now Pawn takes C6
and we do have we do have Rook D6 Rook
D6 plate and after Rook D6 I'm going
after this Pawn but I'm thinking there's
a weakness on F5 and maybe I got Rook B7
check I'm sensing that a niche actually
might have some opportunities here
because Rook takes C6 I got 94. the pawn
on F5 is a little bit weak I've got
Knight E3 ideas as well thinking this
idea might be bad but let's say I push
C7 okay if you play Rook C8 okay I have
Knight A3 and I I just want to put
Knight on B5 and then that looks yeah
secure the pawn on C7 thank you very
much that uh that's a that's a really
powerful uh passer yeah I should
probably take on C7 here and play down
in exchange with a knight on D3 yeah
sure probably good drawing chances but
that is already a demonstration of how
quickly the advantage is turned and
again I I'm sorry uh Nasi what is the
clock times for Richie I know Richie's
in a he he looks nervous and he's
nervous for a reason right right he only
has one minute on the clock and still
has to make three moves while Anish has
22 minutes and a crucial moment right
here C6 C7 and Knight A3 and again I'm
I'm trying to put together something
like for example if I'm white and I play
a move like whoo Rook B5 and I say a
gift me the part if you play Rook take
C6 which is maybe not a good move or not
I go Knight D4 and what I want to say is
maybe I'm wrong but uh First Impressions
is
you know I'm taking over you know like
on a good day I get to play Rook G7
Checkmate we all know that the the those
types of uh winning
um procedures if you will so I'm feeling
like Anisha has opportunity uh VAR is is
the window there
absolutely he I mean uh he made so much
progress compared to like about 10 moves
ago where all his pieces were on the
back crank and now I think a reaching
needs to be accurate with accurate play
he should be able to hold but definitely
the advantages on an issue side the you
know big change in the momentum in this
game here now suddenly there is a past
Pawn on a sixth Rank and I like to move
C7 here suggested by Nazi I think that's
the best move here and I think we might
see an end game where black will take on
C7 lose the exchange and we get this
four on three with the strong Knight on
D3 right which I think you're probably
gonna be able to hold with the precise
player but definitely you're gonna have
to be defending it for a while which is
very unpleasant because uh you know he
he had a great position he was probably
thinking maybe he can win this game
right and you know tie for first and now
suddenly he has to work very hard not to
lose this game well precise a two huge
turnarounds as we're seeing nepo implode
right maybe Richie as well uh but we're
seeing potentially a lot of decisive
games please I want to jump to our uh
game elevation against ding but it looks
like p7 check not C7 Rook B7 check King
G6 was played quickly but I'm with you
I'm I'm on the ding upon on E3 it looks
like black has uh extra material and the
conversation
sorry for interrupting guys there was
one a very interesting moment in this
game so I want to show you this moment
here where he played the move Bishop D2
yeah Nick Lorenz came here current
position is actually losing actually
it's a big Advantage for drink but right
here he had a chance here to try uh
fioruja probably his last last chance to
complicate the matters and in order to
do that he had to find some incredible
moves here so the first is the move H5
because he had played this movie H4 with
the idea to protect but also at the same
time you always have to look for the
opportunity to play this move right so
he probably didn't play this one because
simply he thought okay what if you
opponent just takes with on you don't
want to take with the Knight because
that will allow the move Knight F7 but
after this he has an incredible resource
in this position
that is Knight H7
no way no way wow so black has two
options can take with the Knight or with
the King if you take with the King
now you play the move Bishop G5 painting
the Knight oh can I play Knight D to E4
Knight to E4 and now this clever move
Bishop B1 comes in into play
and now you're pinning and King
is the best move Bishop takes E4 and
black is still maybe a little bit better
but this would have been his best chance
Knight takes C4 Bishop E7
D2 amazing uh
oh sorry oh yeah Bishop F6 check
probably just King G6 there okay so 92
and the same game is uh I think white
has uh decent chances to hold this
position it's still very complicated but
the line after five yeah but the line
after Knight H7 it's even more uh crazy
if he plays the move Knight H7 because
now you're down a piece and down two
pawns but you have some very strong
attack here and black needs to be
careful so for example Queen takes H5
now right and here you can play the move
king h8 or F6 but it will lead to the
same outcome actually F6 now you want to
bring your queen into the defense
now
Rook H1 putting pressure on H7 and now
black has to find the only move King h8
defending the Knight now you play this
move that is very very easy to miss this
queen G6
wow and Rook G8 you think okay I can
just play this move try to get rid of
the queen I'm about to win this game and
now we see the if Bishop G8 you have
Rook G8 but here the very unexpected
Rook takes H7
coin takes H7 oh and queen F6 you cannot
play Rook G7 because d8 is hanging and
if you go to G7 Queen H4 check Queen H7
Queen F6 would have saved the game for
alireza you know I gotta tell you bar
that's a great variation but I want my
opponent's Pockets to be checked after
he comes up with Knight H7 what a move
and what about the current position the
current position the current position is
he just played the move Rook 81 six
minutes for alireza dink has four
minutes it's uh uh pretty much a winning
Advantage if dink can find this move
Knight D E4 not a difficult move to find
at all the F7 is hanging that's the
problem that's why it's maybe a little
bit he's calculating but if this move is
played he's just winning because if
let's say Rook takes d8 okay Rook takes
did now you have a very strong threat of
Rook D2 precisely and if you play the
move Bishop E3 just try to collect the
pawn back there is a tactic Knight takes
G3
discovered attack on division E3 you
have to interpose this move 96 check
just to make sure you don't lose
immediately after capture
King takes G3
Bishop B3 but this is just a losing
position because black has a better King
as well and now E5 is coming up with the
idea of Knight H5 we have an update uh
think played 94 but the wrong night I
think to E4 absolutely this looks like a
inaccuracy now Bishop D6 will allow
furuja to completely get back into the
game here Bishop takes D6 eliminating
this nine Knight D6 is the only move
because of the Rook F7 threat and after
96 Bishop takes F7 whoa whoa stop for
just a second because there is Rook text
no Rook takes D6 and Rook takes F7 is
going to be my Rook d52 at the end of
that line yes so sorry can please
continue so the best way actually white
has options now even here guys you can
also play Knight F7 or Bishop F7 but I
think it will lead to the same outcome
at the end Bishop takes F7 okay Knight
takes F7
Rook takes F7
queen queen F7
Knight takes F7 and now
hook txt xd1
Queen takes D1
and uh E2 yeah King F7 is the only move
because if you play E2 queen
d77 go ahead and make a queen you make
it
right and now Knight E5 is made
incredible King F6 Knight G4 is about
three so and if you go to uh f8 Queen F7
made Queen Jade will lose to the move uh
Queen F7 and if you play King H6 then
Knight G4
and now Queen H7 takes and queen G6
Checkmate and if you play the move King
h8 instead of King 86.
ah then simply just take on the eight
and queen F7 will give a mate here so
that's why we cannot play the move E2
it's possible that maybe dink missed
that well this is going to be an insane
game because they have 10 more moves to
make nine more moves to make and now
King takes F7 four minutes yeah sorry
Queen E2 here and here uh White is a
little bit better white is the only one
with the winning chances here in this
variation VAR the the game's gonna blow
up in the next few moves and both
players are literally at four minutes
for it again now see how many moves did
you say uh they just made move 30 so 10
more moves to go
heart beats per minute you know and
everything else uh this is a three
result yeah yeah it can happen guys
anything can happen here yo we'll keep
an eye on this as okay Bishop takes D6
as you suggested F7 and I don't know but
I just have the feeling that uh with
that last move the way he played it
Bishop takes D6 yeah yeah yeah but it
was also like happiness too like he's
doing it with a little relish that we're
ready to pounce on the F7 upon Knight F6
to E4 spoiled dings all of ding's
advantage in one move
and through the magic of Television we
get to see a repeat uh yeah Bing was
reaching for the night but it was Knight
D60 E4 that was going to bring him the
advantage not the Knight f60 E4 we're
gonna go back to well it's a second here
we go oh nope that's uh
that's Perugia with the uh
with a little twist
yeah
he says that he can pick up F7 and of
course yeah of course uh okay we will
we'll get to that but the point was that
after E3 Rook D1 this moment was key
night on D6 to E4 uh voluntarily giving
up this Pawn on F7 you're welcome to
take it but those variations where you
do take it don't work out very well for
the first player and in the meanwhile
Rook D2 is on uh on Black's agenda
including also ideas of Knight G3 the
current position Nasi uh you know
sometimes you get these kind of
positions where you have
at this a desire to be one point one
side or another but I've got to tell you
in that position where I get to play
Queen versus rook and night night I I
freely admit you've got a great
Pawn on YouTube you might be thinking
that after YouTube has just went in and
missed that Queen D7 let's do a
checkmate
from afar he couldn't from afari
I've got a I gotta say I would be
surprised if white doesn't win this at
the 2800 Club level the reason is
because you're going to put your King on
E1
and at a certain moment your queen is
going to be free to pick up all the
pawns exactly and I'm thinking Black's
King whether you whether you make a king
walk majestically to the queen side or
you stay on the king side I think the
queen is is too strong and white can
also create a pass Pawn on the king side
so that helps a lot thanks to the
majority there as well so we think uh
VAR that after Knight takes D6 the
current position we think those
positions where you play the Queen
versus rook and Bishop uh
long-term uh farooja should win white
should win yeah he definitely has an
advantage in that end game right uh yeah
he's been now he's down to a minute yeah
and uh he in that end game in order to
win he needs to regroup uh regroup with
putting a king on it too so he can move
the queen freely so Bishop F7 player I
think this will lead to the uh same
thing well the problem is you have to
take on F7 because Bishop takes F7
introduces the idea of 96 check which is
devastating so all of these trades
pretty much forced and the players are
going right down that line
and
Rook takes D1 and looks forced
as long as thing doesn't push E2 here
yeah right this is the key moment here
exactly so you were suggesting Nasi that
when in his Mind's Eye when he played
the move Knight E4 he got to this
position did Ding laryn and he thought
well I could be winning with the move E2
and quite possibly forgot Queen D7 turns
the tables completely that's possible he
had to take the Knight and now the move
Queen E2 and eventually bringing the
king to E1 that takes care of the time
trouble by the way because they played
all of these moves please they still
have five moves to go but right now it's
simplified simplified very much so right
I do think black can still hold this
with accurate play you think
earlier I thought maybe why it could
pick up B7 and G6 but now I'm thinking
black can just play Bishop C5 and B6
okay so Queen side pawns will be safe so
let's secure the clean site bonds as you
say uh by the way I did notice that I
did have a queen's bed okay let's let's
get to a position that we can both agree
mutually agree and black Rook is also
free it can move to D file and try to
play actively yeah but it's one of those
things the power of the queen uh is so
her ability to change directions
uh whether it be on a diagonal or a file
okay King G7 now in the immortal words
of Nikolai menev gift meet your part
yes I have to defend with Rook D7 I
didn't want to do exactly and now you
you gave me a clue uh earlier when you
said
but you can create a past Pawn as well
as white can create a past Pawn on the
king side I want to play G4 I want to
play Queen E5 check I want to play H5
and I want to keep you busy yeah it's
going to be very difficult to hold for
work one thing one suggestion maybe guys
maybe the best is to keep the Rook on an
e-file at all times okay and let's put
the King on G7 so as soon as we white
moves the queen we have this idea of E2
okay so like let's say in this position
yeah so if the queen moves we play
E2 and now Bishop F2 is a serious threat
exactly
so we'll just kind of and now uh maybe
rookie seven first and now some Bishop
E3 ID as possible
Bishop
E3 ideas yes yes so thank you Bishop D2
and can go Bishop to D2
so if black manages to push E2 then
that's holding for a block yeah I think
this is probably the best way to try to
hold this position because now uh it's a
little bit you don't have a threat
basically here you can take the pawn I
have Bishop
yeah yeah
interesting so I I need to unwind I want
to put my king on E2 obviously and to
maintain that pawn on E3 for as long as
I can and by the way Queen E2 on the
board as expected uh did that move
Bishop C5 injure you by the way Bishop
C5 I noticed there was this queen check
maybe I'm not losing it though King G7
because you can't really afford to take
it
is
busy you should have Perpetual probably
probably yeah okay so you can get away
with the bishop C5 and uh but probably
easier just to start with the multi G7
just don't even know I was about to say
maybe even here there is this move B4
the difference is if I do capture the
the bishop this way I I'll get my queen
back to the E1 Square
um all right but King G7 might be the
best way just to sidestep all of these
variations but this is what I wanted to
say if I could play H5
and the difference oh my king is I have
Rook f8 here I was about to say my
King's not only too far
I wanted to be able to play Queen takes
H5 with Tempo and magically transport my
king to E2 in one turn I don't think the
fide rules allow that I mean brilliant
idea though yeah you have to admit it's
very insightful and a great
understanding if one is important yes
otherwise if black Rook
cut the king off on file then the queen
won't be free precisely and I do want to
get my king obviously the E1 I think
thanks to the simplified position we can
take a look at some of the other
positions has napo's
self-destruction been completed when we
left it we more or less said yes he did
play the move King G3 F2 Knight C5 takes
takes
perhaps Rook H2 check earlier was better
but in any case this still looks like
it's all on one goal if you will yes MBL
looking very good here
you just push E4 now
four looks really excellent I'm still
sorry help me out here if I go check for
just a second it's very good too and
print the other Rook yes exactly King G3
uh
maybe maybe your your ideas of E4 uh are
looking at 10 times better now that you
know your Rooks are somehow in the game
I don't know this is looking terrible uh
hopeless in fact for uh I would have to
play Knight G2 exactly
Knight to G2 and then
I've got the bee Pawn in my pocket but
again I think that E4 well okay uh not
the the the clean Victory I want you
mentioned E4 also did you mention Rook
E2
something to be said something to be
said for you know doubling Brooks on the
second rank something like this Knight
F1
looks Grim doesn't it Knight F1
oh boy
yeah yeah just everything uh Anish Anish
and Richie I think they reached smooth
40 yes
okay when we left it we kind of felt
that with the move C7 on each slightly
better because you're going to force a
winning exchange he went check night
before C7
this looks this looks definitely drawn
but uh if you're getting these uh
these endings and the clocks are they
still a factor
they'll see no they just made move 41.
okay cool and Wesley so wanting to join
his compatriot with a plus two score how
is he doing when we left it he was
really enjoying himself he had this uh
wonderful night uh diac defending as
tenaciously as he has been throughout
the whole tournament but not enjoying
the tournament I mean just like you know
if you walk away from a tournament for
argument's sake it doesn't matter with
seven draws and two losses and you go
wow
but of the seven draws five you were do
you know like worse at defending you
just feel like Ugh terrible this this is
uh one of those positions where at you
know Daniel's not going to be happy but
I'm sure coming into this tournament
against these guys he was expecting that
he would be defending some most of the
games yeah but at the same time you know
hey you know I've got my ambitions too
who you know I I enjoy the opportunity
we're gonna sneak in a break after this
uh time control has been reached and we
will see you on the other side of the
bridge
foreign
[Music]
Vlad first of all tell us a bit about
yourself I know you're a pretty decent
player as well
um okay this is on a relative scale
depends how you define decent I'm a 2000
rated ELO player I love the game very
much and I'm very happy to be here
amongst the true professionals but
you're also a coach as well do you have
any players we know that there's some
youth competitions going on around here
do you have any players uh here any
students so not at the moment actually
I've been specializing in coaching a
subset of adult improvers as they like
to call themselves on Twitter using the
hashtag chess punks so most of my
students are adult improvers and right
now I'm trying to scale down a bit on
the number of students because I just
started a new job
you've been here since the beginning I
remember I saw you in the first edition
uh of the grandchester held here in
Bucharest how do you feel uh like this
has progressed in the four years that
we've been holding this tournament here
in Bucharest well actually that's a very
good question I don't remember my first
time when I was visiting the grand trust
tour but I have to say that I really
loved last year's Edition it was my
favorite of course we're hoping that
this year's Edition is going to surpass
that but uh the one reason why I really
loved last year is because I got to hang
out with Levon aronian and his wife we
just had a great time and I really
missed them yeah but this year we have
the world champion for the first time in
Romania we didn't have Magnus previously
in the previous years but now we have
ding Loren we also have the Challenger
they just battled it all out in a world
championship match how do you feel how
do you sense their energy right now well
I'm not surprised to hear to see that
Ding made a draw in the first round and
it looks like Jan's position despite
having a very you know like active King
on D4 it looks like black might have
some chances to hold but then again
don't rely too much on my evaluation
please trust stockfish more Vlad thank
you very much for joining us so much
foreign
[Music]
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85 000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
over the roughly one and a half
Millennium of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor for human Affairs
and a French
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back and uh here are our results
right while we're on a break we had
another result another draw between Gary
and Robert and Richie May Rue the fact
that he let something slip today one
definitely got away of the three
remaining games on the other hand we are
seeing something absolutely absolutely
remarkable as Challenger nepo with a
very big Advantage is now in a losing
position Champion world champion ding
again very big Advantage is now on a
losing position as both Challenger and
Champion implode we think tiredness
might be a factor but boy that's a big
big big turnaround uh VAR and then
you've got the remaining game of farugia
versus mvl where we think pardon me uh
you've got the nepo game in front of you
absolutely yeah I'm still a little bit
shocked how Neville turned his really
big Advantage into this position here
and we're about to see a win for mvl he
just played the E4 move which makes a
lot of sense to try to break that pawn
chain and after the capture he can even
play a move like Rook H4 to bring the
Rook into the game and attack on G4 here
so I think it's just completely hopeless
but we can go over some of the lines to
see how mvl can actually bring the point
home here so after E4 you have to take
back otherwise if it takes F3 so for
example take and Rook H4 there are there
are other options too Rook B3 is very
good as well but I like this move to
include this piece into the game here
now the threat is simply to take on G4
and with many ideas yeah if you play
Knight E3 try to protect that pawn no
simply Rook takes P3 attacking then
now you just ignore the fact that your
b-pawn is saying you just continue
pushing for example 93 is also not a
winning move but here you can just again
continue advancing the part now you're
threatening to play A2 and Rook B1 and
you should be able to win the game
pretty easily nepo 2 crook takes B6
and to
E4 takes F3 on Black's agenda yeah you
can take he takes F3 or also Rook H4 is
another option here in this position but
let's let's just take let's just take
now the threat is made to mate so you
need to do something yes The Rook D2 is
the only move if you play Knight D2 you
will simply lose to the move rook d8 and
you will be losing your uh Knight on D2
here so you're gonna have to play the
move Rook D2 which is the only move here
and
here actually you have to find the only
move to win it looks pretty obvious
natural
yes and uh
let's see Rook C6 trying to put pressure
all right now we have this nice tactic
guys Rock Texas
H1 check King F2 check Knight E4 check
if you go King E3 uh maybe rookie one
maybe rookie one or just even yeah
rookie I like rookie one here actually
rookie one it's better than Knight D2
also wins yes as well here so so if you
take Knight takes D2
I'm just trying to see if there are any
chances to get some comfortably here but
I think it's just simply losing after
you take this Pawn on B3
um Rook takes E6 King F7
um
Rook takes Rook to six Rook to A6 that's
a very important move here Rook
I think H3 check because you cannot go
to E4 of the Knight C5 So eventually
this pawns are going to be blockaded and
black will consolidate and win but uh
it's not the only move here actually in
fact there is a stronger move in this
position for black and that is the move
Rook H4
not an easy move to spot the point is
now after you take you immediately
threatened to move Rook to G and white
just doesn't have a good move yes Rook F
Rook C6 pardon me Rook C6 yeah that's
the main line we just take uh and then
the difference after Rook D2 G4 is
hanging yes now Rook G2 is so strong
yeah and if you go here Rook takes G4
check
oh looks terrible devastating actually
King H1 and now just simply Rook B1 and
I pick up the Knight
devastating
uh
Jan is going to be so uh distraught with
himself after this game let's turn our
attention to a game uh where Wesley so
is threatening to join the lead uh
remember that Wesley had
a clear uh first at one moment and when
we left he's only half Point behind the
leader right now precisely and if he can
win against Daniel Dion Knight D3 pardon
me H4 F6 Knight B3 we understand from
Wesley's perspective what this was all
about he wants to play Knight A5 Knight
C6 and simply Target the fact that this
bishop is so passive uh after Knight B3
Rook C2 check the I maybe maybe we're
giving
are we giving Daniel an opportunity to
kind of like
pin ourselves
and if we try to play King D3 and King
C3 I think problem is Rook G2 possibly
yes probably there so Rook C2 check on
the board Bishop to D2 again we
understand what Wesley's aiming for uh
rugby two
uh how close is this for Wesley has he
I looks like he just he blew his
Advantage here guys yeah now some F5
ideas coming up for black to generate
Contra play with the Knight F6 at some
point but yeah it's just Rook is very
active in this pin is very unpleasant
also yeah you have you're gonna be able
to get some Contra play here you can
even maybe play the move G5 at some
point but right here he had a very
simple idea yeah so he could have played
the move Knight F1 Knight F1 yes the
point is now you want to play Bishop D
D2 and we know we want to bring that
Knight to E3 here it's it's the best
Square for the Knight because you're
gonna have the Knight F5 and the desired
Square on C4 right you don't have to
worry about getting pinned or anything
here and this is actually a very large
Advantage here for White and the next
one is Bishop D2 Knight D3 and your
Bishop can go to B4 you can apply a lot
of pressure here I think very very
unpleasant position for black and good
winning chances would have been for
Wesley here so I think you just simply
overlooked this idea so so Knight B3 was
just a step in the wrong direction
exactly yeah he probably thought Knight
B3 I played King D2 then I go Knight A5
and I will just slowly win this game and
it just overlooked this Rook C2 Rook B2
idea interesting uh I was attracted to a
completely different approach myself or
white I'm looking across the board and
I'm seeing this horrible horrible setup
of these four dark Square pawns and this
terrible Bishop on E7 and I'm thinking
to myself let's let's
uh help my opponent keep his pawns on
the dark squares I was attracted to an
idea of G4 and let me just point it
Point
pardon me boldly point out the whole
conception which was to to just totally
keep you cramped uh you know and
the white squares the black bones are on
the black square and the bishop Black's
Bishop is just so bad
G4 would have been also a great plan yes
a very good plan G4 with the idea to you
know weaken the live scores yeah in the
Northwest the barbaric Northwest we
refer to such a bishop on E7 as septic
it's the septic Bishop that just stinks
to high heaven F7 F6 but
this is a this is quite the swing guys
because uh Wesley uh is doing fine he's
undefeated plus one everything's going
well but we've we've been saying he's
leaving points on the table
and that he could have even had a
greater score than he currently has he
had a good position against mvl he
acquiesced to a a repetition and a very
good position today that he may have
spoiled with his last few move give DX
some credit he's so good at defending
worse positions
against this guys it's so difficult it's
a skill that you don't kind of run I I
know when Sergey was getting the
minister of defense ranking and all that
good stuff still it's not something that
you're supposed to be that boastful
about look at me I get to I get to
defend better than anybody else well
well done well done
um okay well keep an eye on this one
tell us why dingler Inn's position is so
bad that the computer is giving him a
minus five Advantage
the main problem for him is actually he
should have put the Rook on E7 and try
to defend uh with the King on G7 try to
create a fortress and every time you
move the queen he can play too but in a
current position here let's take a look
uh the problem here uh White is going to
advance G4 G5 and pick up the G6 spawn
and then the past boss will go through
so so so in this position for example uh
so King E7 and Rook F2 was cause was the
whole the whole concept yes was
completely 87 was the blunder in the
current position here after the move
King F6 you just simply play a G Force
G4 yeah you just want to put upon uh you
know G5 you also you can play H5 next so
let's say you take on B2 yep right you
you can Rook F2 to try to win a pawn
right G5 right
now King G7 King G7 yep Queen E5 check
got me
have to go back
back to uh sure and check again well I
can I can I can already win the G6 Pawn
exactly I can already win the G6 Pawn
here
um and that's just devastating yeah
Queen E6 check for example and when I
pick up the G6 Pawn I'm also covering
the B1 Square yeah you can you can't
even give me a check and in this
position even if you push let's say this
one you still don't have a move you
don't have Bishop F2 doesn't like have
here rugby one rugby two checks yeah
that was why I I was playing H5
flippantly but uh VAR was boldly
pointing out the obvious Queen takes G6
b square and you win the pawn and by the
way Black's King is in a soon to be
mating net so actually The Rook on F2
gives no play yep G4 is played and I
think uh uh we're gonna see a
resignation pretty soon there is just
nothing you really can do you don't have
any plan here in this videos are about
to win second game in a row well we've
seen the Fabi all smiles after two wins
in a row I my suspicion is we're going
to see a lot more smiles from Volusia as
well uh thanks to this back-to-back wins
but
uh again this is a big turnaround uh
dingler in at one moment we were talking
about a very significant Advantage for
our newly crowned world champion
and a swing
and I can show or how or how he could
have actually win the game please so
move number 30 when he played Knight F
E4 this was the blunder and instead he
should have just played Knight D E4 in
this position
and he might have missed this idea Rook
takes d8 yeah Rook takes d8 Knight F7
because actually excuse me Knight F7
right away because it may seem you're
just losing the pawn here but it's very
very nice idea Rook takes D1 yeah
you can you cannot take back with the
queen because then you're gonna lose to
this nice tactic Knight G3 King takes or
Bishop takes you're losing The Rook
after the move E2 here 14 the king and a
rook so you have to take back with the
rook and for a moment it seems like
you're controlling everything and now
Knight is going to come back to G5 but
then this very strong move Knight F2
attacking The Rook here
and Queenie for checks Queen E4 check
but first you have to move the Rook so
let's say Rook F1 yeah yeah we have the
queen E4 is winning also you can play a
very subtle move Queen D7 now
threatening to play Queen two H3 and
also you have a some ideas with queen C6
as well here too Knight G5 Force bar
Knight G5 is forced
well A4 Pawn is also hanging here but
you can start with this check first
spoken like a man true to my heart yeah
now Knight F3 and uh
uh you can play Knight H5 is very good
as well here it's just I like night age
yeah now F4 are you gonna take on F4 and
uh this is a very strong pin just just
concept is very strong with Pawn only
three and Knight on F2 it it looks
extremely strong here for black Air
wow uh
really a huge missed opportunity and I
just I mean the resilience of ding as
he's showed during the World
Championship it was nothing short of
superhuman but I gotta tell you a loss
like this will really really sting
because you know it's it's such a huge
turnaround uh to go from a winning
position uh to a lost position by the
way I'm looking at the game between and
nepo and mvl we were we were alloweding
the fact that uh Rook H4 was really
strong but I got to tell you when you
give me this position give me the fun
grab the Fawn threaten mate in one you
know how can you how could you possibly
stop yourself from doing this Rook D2
only move Rook F1 and we've seen that
there's a combination in the offing that
begins with Rook takes F1 check followed
by one Ken white play Rook F2 to avoid
that combination let's take a look Rook
to F2
and
maybe Rook H3 I know I was about to say
it looks so good that I'm wondering
about the move Rook H3 just you know
reminding uh uh White of the fact that
he can barely barely move he can only
move the other Rook on B6 none of the
other pieces can move exactly the other
move and then the Knight could jump to
D3 well oh excuse me pardon me I've had
this nasty cold for some time and I once
again uh it's it's that that same
combination 1993 can I play B6
hope for some miracle oh sure sure
Knight to D3 now
uh
some very nice checkmating combinations
no I don't I I sorry I don't even think
I need to be fancy I think I can just
take on F2
and take on B3 uh I I wanted to be you
know stylish
if you will but I don't think even uh
it's necessary to be stylish I think I
can just simply capture
it would be be gross about it and take
it the night of two I was gonna play B7
but it doesn't make sense because you
still have Rook B3 simply right
87 B7
I'm somehow I'm still kind of like
looking for mates yes I'm kind of
shocked that they're oh there must be me
yeah something like this right
may I introduce
one of the one of the many check mating
patterns that I mastered as a 1200 or
you can start with Rook H1 the reasser
in that line I was waiting for the coach
to come in it's a reflection deflection
a deflection deflection nice uh however
it ends I'm pretty sure nepo is not
going to be a happy man uh here after
this move Rook B1 and you know what you
were just saying about being so tied up
once I got into a position where I was
in an eternal pin and I felt so helpless
this physical sense of being bound and
it was just a terrible feeling I said
never again I will never ever allow uh
these Eternal pins again this pin of The
Rook on the first rank this is really
well devastating and a yawn knows it
incredibly well that he has spoiled uh
you know as a player I can feel his pain
right now oh absolutely yesterday's loss
and then today spoil in such a good
position and for Rouge the opposite the
Euphoria of winning back-to-back games
we do believe that
alireza is close to that and once again
let's go to Wesley so because how
how badly did he blow it uh I want to
put it out like that to you for isn't it
possible that I can somehow kick this
Rook out of B2 so that I can make Knight
to A5 to C6 and eventuality in other
words can I play the move King to D1
King to C1 and boot this Rook away
from the the B file you can actually you
probably need to try to do that yeah sir
but okay black has two options even not
even one here how to generate control
play one is to play F5 right try to
create the weakness only four and then
play King F7 and jump in with a knight
on F6 and the other option is just
different G5 actually you can do it
because E5 yes a little bit surprising
for me as well but if you take uh yeah
if King C1 just uh Rook A2 okay Rook A2
and can't I somehow I'm just dreaming
VAR of Knight A5 and
um Knight C6 yes let's see here if you
bring the king to everyone now I can
play uh Rook A4 or Rook A6 let's say
okay I want you to be as Cooperative
okay as possible so let me play Rook A4
okay and then Knight A5 Knight A5 he has
Rook A4 on his board
instead of okay six oh I I wanted I
wanted you to be cooperative okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah
Knight A5 yes
uh now takes on H4 creating a weakness
on H4 first good for you and when you
capture back F5 again this is a critical
move you need this move F5 otherwise
you're just simply losing here so F5 is
very important and you're just in time
thanks to uh the H Pawn I I mean Knight
C6 I was trying to trap the bishop but
I'm just saying that Bishop H4 right
and you're just you just Escape
you know my my route before
Bishop B4 yes Bishop B4 and just the
king F7
okay F7
looks a little dangerous foreign
away you go
away you fly hmm yeah it seemed like you
might get mated but it's your take is
actually just taken back with the King
now Rook F7 just Knight F6
wow
and now the ponds are also split now
it's going to be a you know very easy to
attack D5 and but again I don't think
you should we should put the Rook on A6
we can put it more active Square on A4
of course
so in view of these ideas of G5 GH as
well as F5 yes does it make any sense
for us to start with the G4 VAR a G4 in
this position yeah
let's see if we play G4 in this position
um
black and play G6 first okay now I go uh
Queen side let's say King D3 King D3 and
now just takes
G4 take takes back and this again this
very important move here absolutely
necessary movies to play F5 F5
black pieces activate very quickly yeah
uh G5 he takes and then G5
I want to try to keep Black's pieces and
then I take on e4 uh gummy dump is
possible yeah okay four and then I go
King F7 with the idea to get Knight G7
and bring the Knight to F5 gosh darn it
I just can't uh white king might get
mated in the center well it was one of
those things I was trying to get in H5
and G6 so let's try taking on F5 first
and then go in G5 okay yeah so so from
the position where you played F5 a move
or two again yes we're gonna take which
which Pawn E4 takes F5 yes G6 takes F5
now we're gonna go G5 to try to keep it
this is sharp this is a lot more sharp
because now black has two connected
passwords white is two connected pass
pawns as well but it looks like it's
just equal so let's see F4 Angels engine
is still giving four triple zeros and
now we have this nice C5 move
uh but just that that will just trade uh
trade Rooks here just to get rid of this
pin well ah
it's so close yeah yeah uh King E4
perhaps tried to uh blockade but now
King G7 King F7 I've got G6 check G6
check and now just takes
takes yes and if you take on E8
even even Bishop page four actually uh
black history black has enough enough
Contra play here because you can't
really move the Knight the bishop is
hanging after the Knight is under attack
so let's say you go Rook B8 and now
black can just simply sit here with the
move Bishop six it's very dangerous if
you move the king king F5 comes in and
then E4 there is a there is a risk
involved in this position if you let
this E Pawn go so just probably have to
sit with Rook B6 Bishop B7 yeah I'm I'm
confused let's say uh for a ding lyric
fans we have uh bad news for you if
you're joining us late uh he is
suffering against Ali Reza uh farusha as
we're expecting Ali razor to pick up
this G6 Pawn which is a very juicy pawn
and a way uh the the white Palms go
there you see it Queen takes G6 and I
wouldn't be surprised of a resignation
uh a short shortly uh didn't happen
yeah it's E5 completely winning now okay
you take King E5 and
with the queen patrolling the uh
diagonal to stop Rook B1 I mean even
something to be suggested like well I
don't know H5 H6 just getting those
Pawns
rolling roll them
yeah
time is not a factor anymore right
no no no no not at all and what about
nepo uh bring us up to date just one
second will be the first person to
defeat the new champion
yes yes yeah yeah
I remember uh after
Anatoly karpov won against Victor
korchnoy in Murano
Victor who was very uh
angry with the Soviets and angry with
Anatoly karpov gave 400 to everybody and
anybody who beat the world champion
Anatoly karpov and I got these 400
checks so I think they're with a
congratulatory note you know I don't
think anybody's doing that for dingler
and he's he's very sweet uh person but
uh you're right he will be the first
player to defeat the world champion
Queenie a check on the board
let's see King F4 what's the big concept
here you can simply produce G6
yeah
and oh because the queen is behind the
e-pawn
uh then the king can move away yes
makes sense
there are just couple of checks there
but then eventually King will go to C4
exactly so Queenie a check King F4
G5 G6 says and you're welcome to give me
a couple of checks and just as you were
saying VAR whites King is very happy to
step yeah and actually if you play E2
yeah sir it's interesting uh it's fine
line there you just right right here uh
G6 E2 yeah no no if check Rook B1 or
Part B G6 yeah Rook B1 check yep kingy
two yep Rook B2 checking you can
actually play even Queen takes E2
because well that's pouring salt onto
the wound isn't it I mean you don't have
to you can just yeah there's no way to
stop a future G7 and a new coronation
maybe D2 check will be played there and
then just King C4 yep uh yeah and just
uh E2 and G7 and we could see the
resignation exactly
so this bishop is really out of place on
B6 it's just you know not the only thing
it's doing is basically defending the E3
Pawn but it's not really helping in any
way to prevent the g-pawn from cleaning
exactly it's not playing uh
in any way an aggressive okay this win
will motivate Ali Raja to come back to
chess more because defeating world
champion must feel
better
it's the best so motivating it it truly
is uh
it's what
I think every chess Grand Master
in the world
motivates them
is their dream of becoming world
champion to begin with
as well as their dream of defeating the
world champion and it's if you are a
grand master it's what
you know like what I lived for that was
what I wanted was to play against them
and I remember this very vividly I was
walking in Hyde Park
on my way in the Phillips and Drew
tournament to uh the Parliament building
in London and I ran into Boris baskey a
former world champion and we were
walking walking walking we were talking
about this that and the other and he
says to me who do you play today
he said yeah sir
enjoy your day in the Sun
and that's exactly what it was for me
you know playing against a world
champion it was like the spotlight is on
you as well as the world champion of
course
um but yeah enjoy your day in the Sun by
the way I won that game that was really
good that was a good day that was a
really good day in the Sun and uh here
we will catch up this is the position
G7 pardon me G5 G6 on the board G7 is
coming up next and ding
a few Spike checks before we
we give it a rest or he's seen enough
what do you think a few more moves
Spike checks yes yes
do you call them Spike checks as well no
you know one last great Act of defiance
before you resign
before you accept your fate exactly
exactly
well G6 all right uh we'll keep an eye
on this game I do want to just check on
nepo because
well
he's still kicking
the pawn okay we we saw a number of
different ways of how uh
white could continue that is to say
h8 and Rook B8 now we were thinking
there was a reason why we might get in a
rook check
oh the one Rook was on B7 King couldn't
go up right but exactly I think right
now it doesn't apply it doesn't apply
eight wreckage eight and
uh be be prepared to swing The Rook
around
I don't know I'm it's still low yeah
exactly wait a minute I mean I want you
know I want to have a cake and eat it
too right there's uh there's something
about uh being a piece up where you
really want to play more forcefully do
you mind if I play rookie one check I
just want to take a look at that D3 okay
now I want to put my Rook on B1
so you're not afraid of kingsy too that
was the dream wait I will take rookie
six first of course
grip takes E6 first and maybe then I can
play King suit too I'll take your Rook
we'll take my room it doesn't work and
I'll put them back
um
it's winning it's not as clean
necessarily as we would like I like your
blue Brook h8 perfectly well by the way
there's nothing wrong with it yeah good
play
good moves
as Bobby Fischer said I believe in good
news
I think the Hulk was I don't believe in
Psychology I believe good news yes
that's exactly right Rook check
so there was a
there was something about wanting to uh
misplace White's King obviously E2 is a
land of King E4 he can play King F6 and
I'm almost made it but I don't know oh
this is perfect this is what I want
I want my Pawn I want to give you a
check you're right it's almost mate but
it's not necessary I don't need mate
this is just enough uh attack the prod
and this guy
um
wow and in their head-to-head match we
have to say at the top of the show one
of a really uh extraordinary things for
us is in classical Chess at least MBL
has almost adoption uh one Victory only
for Depo 10 draws but look at that six
losses that's pretty huge well we can
add one more to that total as we do
expect the Frenchman
uh to win and make it seven and we do
believe that Ding the last few minutes
has kind of been shaking his head and
resigned himself to the fact that well
there's nothing
there's nothing more to say
and
it's one of the worst feelings when you
lose a game and the day after that is a
rest day yes
yes that's right now alireza left the
board so yeah he can't resign what do
you do now yeah it was first of all a
big shout out to our friend Vichy Anan
but it's very nice when vishi of all the
players in the world is talking about
chess commentary for world championship
match because talk about a player who's
won so many world championship titles I
think he told me and apologies
especially if I got this wrong that he's
won over course of his illustrious
career eight world championship titles
when you start adding these Blitz and
wrap it in
and he said
one of the worst things that can happen
in World Championship chess matches is
you lose the game on the day before the
rest day because then it's perpetually
with you whereas when you win on the
game the day before the rest day you're
carrying yourself so much happier and uh
and he gave us some very nice well he
gave the world some very nice insights
with his comments and I think doing is
really waiting for his opponent to
return at this moment
nope
but we can also say that since this this
will be second win in a rough or feroza
maybe he doesn't want to rest there he
just wants to keep wrong yes yes
sometimes you get in that uh in that
mode where you're winning day after day
after day don't stop the tournament
what's your longest winning streak
uh
no idea no idea you never thought I
never never counted that really okay
yeah yeah and uh VAR what's your longest
winning I mean you know in Grand Master
play and stuff uh seven games bravo
bravo
me too twice
and you said and you felt like don't
don't stop let's let's keep the
tournament rolling right yeah absolutely
the US Championship was four in a row in
2014. nice and it was really good
feeling you just after a while you get
the feeling that you can't lose it
exactly exactly the world is your oyster
everything everything is going great
no there is one trick here maybe he
didn't can try to play King F3
uh just trying to set up a background
Checkmate here yes King F3 uh but then
uh you're having made in one yeah
interesting made in one and then you
have to play some accurate checks like
Queen F7 check okay first of all just
kick that queen king E4 okay somehow you
might be threatening Perpetual possibly
I'm not sure yeah you are maybe but then
you just play Queen C4 check Queen C4
check okay F3 again you have to go yep
and then Queen D5 check again to make
sure there is no background uh ideas and
let's say King F4 King F4
and now it's finally time to play G7 and
we're saying we are no longer worried
about our checks Rook B1 check
King E2
Rook B2 check yeah and here you have to
find a move King F1 King F1 I found King
D1 but King F1 yeah King F1 and uh if
Rook B1 you can just go King G2 Rook B2
just King goes to H3 simply and if you
play the move E2 you simply return to E1
and Rook B1 check you will pick up the
E2 pawn bishop F2 doesn't work because
of uh King takes F2 and you don't have
King G3 actually I have a G8 Queen with
a check and the last
would be king E3 and then
Queen check only five King F3 Queen F5
check King E3 and now B1 square is
covered there is no Bishop F2 time to
Queen yeah
you might say it on the board well I
mean you know
in view of the fact that the move King
F3 does give you a chance to check meet
you you should play one move right you
should you should play it you should get
in it's it's better than a spike check I
mean the threat of mainten one
while we're waiting for Dean to make a
decision if we jump to Wesley's game it
looks like a complete Runner does it
like things have really oh uh the Rooks
off the board and Black's night is
actually in the game so after Rook B2
the the line that Wesley allowed F5
perfectly what a great time to make that
break
Wesley acquiesce to the trade of Rooks
and now
okay it's still okay slightly better but
yeah I mean the the the the Lion's Share
of the advantage is gone it's just gone
yeah because of the Contra play against
the E4 Pawn you cannot freely move your
king let's say to B5 because you're
always going to be bothered by move
Knight F6 or Knight F2 putting pressure
on that weak Pawn on e4 wow another well
I mean I really felt that that Wesley
more or less from the late opening early
middle game if you will
and gotten the kind of strategic
position that he's so good at I mean
once he gets his grip on you and he gets
the type of position he wanted and he
got it today he usually doesn't let his
opponents escape and it was right here
where he got seduced by this idea of
Knight B3 to A5 to C6 imagining himself
to trap this bishop overlooking the fact
that when he played Knight B3 his
opponent could craftily put his behind
and force the trade of Rooks as we've
seen and that's quite the save and
somewhere in his hotel room I'm sure
Fabiano is applauding Daniel diock and
saying good game well done nicely played
uh I'm glad you didn't give Wesley a big
point today Ali ruza versus ding Loren
that is winning and finally let's go
back to yawn
oh wait a minute after oops excuse me
after Rook check King here
okay Jake he did the camera yes check
and we've caught up yeah I was wondering
yes
nice
thanks to the a pawn black is went in
yes yes
there is
if you play Rook D6 I can even bring my
king over even more King E7 right
exactly but uh the whole point of being
able to play Rook B8 and as you say get
that pawn rolling uh is decisive somehow
whenever I see an a pawn I'm always
reminded of this article by janhein
Donner Grandmaster Donner where you know
he's giving this lecture
on this most Beauty a pawn you've ever
seen and he said it's all about you oh
do the pawn you know go little Juan go
and bring me glory and uh Wesley
repeating in this
this game with uh Daniel Dak
in
is
still taking his time
right last few minutes
yeah I don't see any other ideas except
King F3 for dink here exactly so so we
are expecting two decisive results today
and even we almost thought hey I I was
almost ready to get you know to go for
the trifecta and say you know we're
gonna see three decisive results so yes
two because it's just uh amazing that
the two decisive results we're expecting
will be losses for the world champion
and the Challenger we said coming into
her day one of broadcasting this was a
very very strong tournament and I think
uh today's results are conclusive proof
of that exact point that when the world
champion as well as Challenger losing
the same round it means you've got a
competitive feel
and uh by the way I want to just thank
our audience again for sending us your
social media tweets we really enjoyed
that and one of them today was what do
you think about such events when Magnus
is missing well when Magnus is missing
you know it's one of those things where
the field is so strong go ahead and
shoot if you choose choose your player
and tell us who's going to win it right
I think we might see a resignation in a
Nepal game as well soon because I think
now he will just he'll just consolidate
bring the king to D6 and uh so and I
sorry to interrupt you uh I'm just
looking at Ding lyron and
he while he his eyes might be towards
the board
it's almost like his thoughts aren't
about the character somewhere else it's
like it is like he's remembering and
he's saying you know like where Becca
move you know 24 I should have played
this and that was probably where I
missed it you know like he's carrying
the baggage of all of the previous moves
and uh
and he's just he's struggling with his
decision to resign or to continue he
decided to continue Rook check King E2
and King D3 this makes it a lot easier a
lot easier simply just King goes to C4
now yes
can he play I know white is winning but
after King C4 if I play Rook G2
so King D3 Rook D2 check King C4 Rook
back over to G2 to get uh out of uh my
idea
E2
G7 E2 yeah pause
it's almost like a you can't take Queen
E2
yeah well I want to be able to I want to
sorry I I guess I was being a little bit
too uh Overjoyed F7 looks actually
easier maybe I think you can pick up the
Rook that's what I want to do I just
want to be able to pick up the road
yes because if I go to G file then you
promote with a check if I go to e-file
and queen D5 just picks up the Rook yeah
thank you that definitely clears the
cobwebs there doesn't it Queen F7 check
yeah that makes it easier easiest of all
do we have a rook check on the board by
the way we have Rook B2 on the board
okay so King D3 is a let's say an
automatic probably King F1 is also in it
instead of King D3 also
I didn't see any reason really why I
have to squirm my way you know uh on the
first rank but I uh but really king of
yeah I always have checks
King G3 Queen E5 check you're right you
always have checks
yeah
true king F1 I guess uh it's a choice
for me King D3 is he went simplest
simple
again the queen on E8 is doing a great
job at uh covering the promotion Square
while at the same time doing a great job
of supporting
the past pawn and now the players have
picked up their Pace a little bit Rook
checking C4 on the board
well that was fun three checks in a row
I mean in the variant of three checks
whatever one yeah we could claim
by the way do you like uh chess variance
some of them yes that can be quite fun
and challenging yes especially once
where
you don't uh you cannot you shouldn't
play like regular chess it's confusing
because I'm calculating like normal Jazz
and that's usually a bad thing a bad
thing so it's a challenge by the way
Rook G2 inviting Queen F7 check and I
think that that is absolutely a
resignation yeah there's nothing to say
after Queen F7 check because as you
mentioned if you go to the E file then
Queen D5 check picks up the Rook
conversely if you go to the G file
G7 is about to promote uh with a check
and because the king is just curious if
of course plays Queen F7 but if you play
G7 and here thing resigns yes
wow yeah is G7 not winning anymore after
you two well that's the thing I mean
I made it a little bit tricky for myself
I I suspect it might still be winning
but I mean you know you kind of feel
like a jerk if you know you you show off
and then it turns out not to be winning
after all and the player's there
well we do have a win and what a win it
was and what a turnaround as Ali Reza I
mean he took some risks unnecessarily
and well it paid off when dingler in
moved the wrong night to E4 and we have
the return of the grantchester champion
he was at -1 now he's plus one he's a
plus one a half a point behind our
tournament leader hubby uh with
everything to play for with four games
going for dingler in my choice in
tournament uh this was a painful loss it
really is a setback we know that things
are slow starter but wow as the two
players sitting at the board I think
both players are still you know uh
reflecting on quite the result uh
jumping to nepo's a game for a moment
because this is another game we're
expecting a resignation A3 oh
oh
no A3 threatening A2 and A1 and if you
take the old shish kebab
Rook H3 check picks up the Rook on B3
okay I have to say that's winning with
Style Bar absolutely very nice movie
tree and I think we will see the as soon
as young comes to the board we will see
the resignation here and my Peak coming
back in the tournament from minus one
nobody that's wants to talk about your
picks I think it's not important messy
you know it was it's the fact that you
could participate you know with the
world's best
right oh boy I picked England I mean
okay yeah and you're right uh
oh no I thought that was a flourish of
the signature by nepo uh there for a
moment as he returned to the board and
I thought he
was he got he got some tea uh teapot
going on
looks like a team
I think it's been a very long time since
he lost two games in a row in a
classical tournament yes
yes
very much so as he came into the
tournament he was talking about gonna
rejoining if you will the 2800 cup club
and as he got off to a good start I said
uh nepo you're gonna have to raise the
bar a little bit there uh get join the
2850 Club you know that's something you
should aspire to and uh now I think this
loss is going to knock him right back
out of the 2800 Club I don't know what
the what the live ratings will show but
this was not good now nepo much like
ding I think is not looking at the
current position more like reflecting on
one wrong yes
uh
boy have we been there before and what
an idiot I am why did I wake up uh why
did I fall out of bed I should have just
stayed at home
but by the way nobody abuses himself
quite like nepo nepo will tell you that
he's the worst player ever that he
shouldn't even be playing chess and
we're all saying dude you know like
you've won two candidate matches and
there you go resignation
with the white pieces too
and for mvl who's been playing like an
idiot he loses yesterday to Fabi in a
miniature or whatever it was Whenever
two days ago in a miniature what a
stunning turnaround today is again uh
nepo had all of the advantages you could
ever dream in an allappin and chess can
be really cruel sometimes and then you
die
exactly exactly and the other game is
about to finish as well I think the ACT
they exchanged the knights and now the
bishop d8 has been played as well
so we're gonna see a repetition in this
game soon
and let's go to Christian in Bucharest
Romania
al-raza back-to-back victories for you
but most importantly I think it's for
the first time that you're beating a
world champion you've tried against
Magnus quite a few times you didn't
manage to get him while he was a world
champion but now you got your first
scalp of a world champion how do you
feel right now
yeah I feel really happy
um and for sure it's easier more
Champion than Magnus but
um of course thing is very strong
um I'm really happy to get this Victory
because now I moved to plus one and it's
really important and this game was not
easy you were actually under pressure
out of the opening out of the middle
game and I think at one point he was
even winning he showed you a move at the
end of the game what was that move it
was
um should we go to the position
absolutely
um it was around here I think I hear him
out he got outplayed here actually
um I think
G6 is a terrible move too big to make
the king weak but already I don't like
each five which were just Knight C5 it's
just econ
he was a bit aggressive and
maybe he felt to be like he has to be
aggressive because he doesn't have two
Bishops so
but yeah he took here here I couldn't
find the
best move Bishop it was really difficult
it's just prophylactic preventing 96
which was the whole problem for me the
whole game first I saw that I'm winning
with Queen C2 in my calculation but of
course Queen C5 and I lose this was the
first cold shower and
and then
I felt like G5 yeah Bishop way too
problem meaning but yeah Knight G5 is
not a good move on here he's okay I
couldn't make bishop for work for me
because Knight H5 is probably just
nothing 25.7 very important yeah and
so I decided it's hanging on with this
Knight on D6 defending but I felt like I
should not be worse here my Bishop only
two so H4 Rook F1 here normal
what's yeah I'm probably like my Bishop
on dito is very bad and
and in fact I want to uh chime in on
this position how did you assess it at
this point because I came into the
playing Hall and you were I think down
to your last six minutes he still had
around double your time yeah it was
getting out of my hand and it was
getting out of my control because in
preview previous moves I was in control
and then I lost the control and I got
down on time but you still looked
comfortable yeah because at least from
the outside yeah because practically
there is always a chance here because
with the bishop 182 but
um so he was also going down on time so
it was very important moments here
yeah he told me after the game Knight D4
that he probably was winning but still I
saw Knight F7 and he told me Rook D2
after the game but I don't think it's a
good one here it's Rook D2 and this
seems to somehow yeah he told me look
takes D2 Knight takes D2 be sure he sees
him his son Rook F4 he told me he has no
idea but I told him I have things and
I've been again but it's such a
complicated position yeah it's really
complicated and understanding for
instance computers is drug test the one
is winning here is really crazy because
you're giving up the D file for no like
and then you plug it with nine yeah okay
this is Knight F2 Knight F2 okay yeah
and for human for instance to all I have
all this bishop H6 Knight G5 it's
difficult yeah so
um yeah for was it only move Knight D4 I
think it was among the only ones yeah
it's such a complicated position and if
you don't do something as black then you
know Bishop D6 is coming you have always
problems yeah you thought for a thing
like six seven minutes he thought for a
while yeah and he settled for draw I
think in his mind he thought he is not
better anymore yeah of course if you've
seen anything before you win
uh he couldn't see it and here I think
he miscalculated 95 checking his mind
like he checked all of this and I think
he maybe here he wanted yeah yeah it's
maybe maybe I'm mistaken maybe he saw
all of this but he probably missed 95
Powers everything yeah this is so nice
so but maybe he saw it and he
voluntarily went for this position
which I think it's really hard to assist
but I thought I'm winning yeah but maybe
strong
um it's robot even if it's draw
objectively it's much easier to play for
yeah you have always checks and yeah and
here I was still lucky that he didn't
gain the time that he needed he has two
I think two minutes here is 36 he still
has yeah four moves to make I think and
he has less time than five minutes here
five minutes dropped down to his last
minute right with this move yeah I felt
he has to keep the king here but it's
still
um I wanted to go here uh maybe
activating visual
so explain to us the decision between
him going towards the center and him
going towards I think he sat here for
three four minutes and he saw that he's
just lost and he gave up I think and he
just wanted to make some movement in the
last second and he didn't understand
that he has a still chance probably
which is also I thought also that I'm
winning now King comes the one and so I
don't have good explanation for these on
because he left the G6 Pawn very weak so
that's why I probably just to defend
that G6 Point yeah and yeah and the rest
is just easy
I just pushed and I pushed the two
points and it's just me well alireza it
definitely feels like you warmed up and
you're finally getting your type of play
uh on the board congratulations big
victory for you today go enjoy it and
we'll see you in a couple of days thank
you very much thank you Christian thank
you alireza well let's take a look at
our standings after a very eventful
round five with some really really huge
wins yeah we have uh few things change
in the leaderboard yes we do so Fabiano
caruana is still in a solid with three
and a half points guess who showed up
our top seat firoza joined uh Wesley so
and Richard rapper was plus two plus one
plus one's four with a plus one score at
50 is Anish and uh MBO yeah quite the
surprise and uh world champion and the
challenge are moving down in the list
with minus one crazy tomorrow is a free
day everyone uh don't tune in tomorrow
but uh but thereafter we do have more
exciting pairings Pride will have Maxima
Sheila grab against rapper well there
you go I talk about a leaders group
right there viac against Geary dig
wanting to come back in the tournament
playing the leader Wesley so but check
this out Fabi versus Perugia our two
tournament uh well leaders if you at the
very top
and let's go to Bucharest with uh
Christian with mdl
Maxim a very difficult game for you you
are on minus one and after the opening
uh it was a difficult position he was
putting a lot of pressure on you but you
are your resilient self and managed to
turn it around how do you feel right now
of course it feels great to to win I
didn't like my position at all I don't
know where I went wrong in the opening
but this end game turned out to be a lot
more difficult to play than I thought at
first
and
then I found a setup that I didn't like
at all with this Knight on B7 let's take
a look but at least
surprised you with this a lot yeah yeah
as you set up and I didn't expect at all
when was the last time you checked the
Olympic
I check it on locations really yeah yeah
like not in this tournament but I
definitely checked it last year like
maybe even this year so yeah but uh
still it's difficult to remember the
details yeah and well and he was also
playing extremely fast yeah extremely
fast and quite well because I just
thought here I should be all right but
then after Knight fd2 I realized yeah
it's not so easy because
yeah
probably the suggestion by computer to
play A5 I didn't want to commit to A5
but turned out in the game I had to so
I'm playing Knight F6 Knight B3
yeah what was it about the position that
you didn't feel comfortable with no
simply
it keeps all the pieces
my ponds are sometimes weak and I don't
have so much space for my
for my minor piece so
I really didn't like
it at all so that's why I decided at
some point to just allow a pair of
Bishops and try to get some contemplary
with this Knight C5
play with the Knights yeah and this was
ugly but
had to be done had to be done
and at this point
it looks innocuous right they open up
the age file but it doesn't seem like
you're doing anything on it no it
doesn't but then suddenly
it did so anyway like my plan was to
exchange pair of folks anyway I want
Rook d8 for instance I have Bishop E7 I
guess I want from C7 he played a bit
carelessly like very fast also to put
pressure on time but yeah suddenly
it becomes tough because
and Bishop D6 I realized I have Knight
D7
and here I saw Bishop C7 has to be a lot
but of course it's tempting to continue
playing yeah yeah Bishop C7 I take and
take I play F6 I thought maybe maybe I'm
even
trying I mean I I don't think so but
like my knight is coming to C5 so it's
very pleasant
and uh if Bishop p7 yeah Knight E5
Bishop G5 I thought this was quite
important but it just wins yeah
very nice and then after B3 I mean at
first like I saw this move but I didn't
consider it seriously and that was a bit
done on time so I was feeling I should
have instead of taking walks maybe but I
was expecting Bishop C7 at the same time
so
um and that's quite unusual for you
you're not very often in time travel
situation was
so anyway
then I realized I have F6 and yeah when
I saw that after Bishop is high of 95
and suddenly like normally it felt like
you know when I exchanged Bishop against
Knight his Knight on G2 is covering
everything but once my opponent is on E5
which seems ridiculous at First Sight
but then I always get E4 and the Knight
on B7 gets into play and then well I
don't know because I I don't know if it
was always winning if he had a draw like
this I really don't know but at the very
least when it get got to rear and you
thought for a while I realized yeah I'm
winning with this hook H3 check at the
end quite important so interesting right
because after Rook to D6
I was trying I was looking uh in the
playing hole at the position and in fact
I had no idea how to assess it and then
I come back and I see minus 3.6 on the
engine
zero chance to lose first of all and
that's I have what looks like a decisive
attack like so you assessed it as much
better for yeah probably winning but of
course I had to prove it and it was not
that easy yeah to intricate I mean today
and to intricate all the details but
can you repeat it was very professional
just because Jan got up so I thought I'm
gonna win time
that's very professional yeah yes group
takes B6 take on F3 be careful not to
get checkmated on G2 yeah
and uh when was it clear for you was at
this point I would assume you were
already kind of sure about the victory I
mean I was not completely sure first of
all I was a Muslim King history but I
knew I I knew that you know his pawns
were stopped and but yeah and I mean I
have I need okay so I think okay
no me actually not I thought I thought
it was
um well then all over
necessary for which but of course it's
nice to to bring his King to F2
yeah Maxim uh a big victory with the
black pieces and especially sweeter
whenever you win against such a strong
opponent such as Jan he's a world
championship Challenger twice he has a
luggage filled with opening preparation
um congratulations we'll see you in a
couple of days thank you
thank you questions then our
congratulations to MBL uh wow still a
huge huge turnaround we saw two huge
turnarounds and our standings have been
really shaken up are there you know our
pairings but let's get some final
thoughts about oops
uh
[Music]
I don't know we want dinner Christian
and daru are very happy
wow uh yeah I've done better let's just
put it like that the final thoughts of a
very eventful first half of the
tournament to begin with we've had five
rounds under our belt but most
especially the turnarounds of today
absolutely huge turnarounds and alireza
could have very simply lose the game but
instead he won same thing for mvl he
managed to win this position I couldn't
believe that he could ever win that
position but the nipple just simply
self-distract and Fabiano's still at the
top with the plus two but now with
alireza coming up I think it's going to
be a very interesting matchup they face
each other next and that could be the
big game of the tournament so I'm
looking forward to to see how they're
gonna come back after the rest day and
see some interesting games we're gonna
go to Christian in Romania
well guys what uh a day and I told you
at the beginning of the broadcast this
is the day before the rest day and you
know these players are going to take uh
extra risks and this is exactly what
we've seen so far Ali Reza against ding
what a game that was what a complex game
in which uh I have to say none of the
players actually knew uh who's better
and why and to be honest nobody knew
unless you have an engine and unless you
have hours and hours of analysis at home
so that was such a complicated game and
I cannot blame thing for not playing
Knight D4 and playing Knight fe4 is such
a trivial decision that makes uh such a
big difference and that was just an
incredible game and of course this one
between Jan and MVR Leon right now it
feels like he's collapsing for the
moment he's definitely going to have to
take this rest day and try to stir the
ship get back into this tournament
because back-to-back losses it's never
easy to recover from especially when
you're already bringing such a damaged
let's say machine from the world
championship match because you know that
took its toll on him so this one is
going to be very difficult for Yan but
we also know how resilient he uh can be
he's shown that time and time again guys
we have an open tournament in front of
ourselves for the next four rounds
tomorrow it's a rest day I'm going to
take my rest I would assume you guys are
going to enjoy your rest day as well and
I will see you in a couple of days thank
you Christian indeed everyone here in St
Louis is looking for tomorrow rest day
but but round six promises to be epic do
join us for round six and in the
meanwhile
good night have a great day thank you
for watching
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited